Welche Sendung ist es? Kleines Rätsel. Welche Sendung hört ihr gerade? Es rauscht, es ruckelt und es knarzt. 0331 70 97 110. Wer sind wir? Wer weiß es? Irgendjemand? Die Klasse? Bueller? Hier ist Chaosradio 103. Zu Anfang hört uns schon keiner mehr zu. Jedenfalls keiner mehr mit Telefon. Hier ist Chaosradio 103. Einen wunderschönen guten Abend. Ah, jetzt ruft einer mal gucken. Ja hallo, möchtest du uns sagen, dass wir Chaosradio 103 sind?
Kutta dachte ich gestern.
Noch nicht mal den Arsch in der Hose dann auch dran zu bleiben, wenn er schon meint, uns verahnden zu können. Nun denn, Chaosradio 103 kümmert sich heute um User Interfaces, also Benutzer Schnittstellen im Allgemeinen und im Besonderen zu Gast im Studio. Er ist einerseits Ellen, wir haben mal wieder eine Frau dabei. Hallihallo, er gehört zu openuseability.org, ist eine der Mitgründerinnen eben dieses, dieser, des, Ellen.
Dieser Plattform.
Dieser Plattform, Dankeschön. Der Sven ist da, Sven ist, guten Abend, einer der Gimper. Das hört sich gut an. Was machst du da genau?
Eigentlich alles. Also ich bin der Maintainer mit Mitch zusammen schon seit ein paar Jahren und wir sind eigentlich auch die, die sehr viel von dem Code schreiben. Und GIMP ist ein Bildbearbeitungsprogramm, was durchaus im Vergleich mit Photoshop nicht scheuen muss. Und da haben wir natürlich sehr viel auch mit User Interfaces zu tun.
Und der Tim?
Genau, hallo, ich bin auch mal wieder dabei. Nach längerer Abstinenz.
Ja und wie ist so?
Es war schlimm, wie es vorher war oder wie es jetzt ist.
Nein, mit dem Bein.
War das jetzt schon wieder einer von den schlechten Witzen, die du vorhin angekündigt hattest?
Ich kündige die neuerdings an.
Nein.
Du wolltest ein paar Announcements machen, bevor wir mit der Sendung anfangen, oder?
Ja, kann ich machen. Ja, was wollte ich denn eigentlich erzählen? Na ja, wir haben mittlerweile Juli, das heißt, die Sommersaison steht unmittelbar bevor. Das äußert sich mal wieder in einer gestiegenen Veranstaltungsfrequenz. Es waren schon so ein paar, aber es kommt jetzt auf jeden Fall noch was tolles auf uns zu, und zwar die Open-Air-Hacker-Konferenz namens What the Heck. Die findet statt in Holland in einer Nische namens Den Bosch, in der Nähe des kleinen schönen Örtchens Box Tell. Dort gibt es ein großes Geländer und dort werden sich dann voraussichtlich so 3.000-4.000 Hacker aus aller Welt zusammenfinden, um dort vier Tage Open-Air-Camping-Konferenz zu machen. Das ist so ein bisschen ähnlich wie die Veranstaltung, die wir auch alle vier Jahre machen. Wir sind sozusagen mit denen immer so ein bisschen im Wechsel. Das sieht alles schon ganz gut aus.
Diese Probleme, die es hat mit What the Heck, die sind aus der Welt. Also mit diesem Bürgermeister, der ja nicht wollte, dass das stattfindet in seinem Dorf.
Genau, die sind aus der Welt, das basierte mal wieder alles auf gehörigen Missverständnissen. Da hat ihm halt jemand gesagt, das wäre alles ganz schlimm. Aber als er sich das dann mal genauer angeschaut hat, da sah das schon wieder ganz anders aus. Der ganze Medienrummel hat dann noch mal sein Übriges getan. Jetzt ist es so, dass die Gewinnnehmigung erteilt ist. Das ist also alles in Butter. Und die Veranstaltung wird wie angekündigt stattfinden. Und hoffentlich auch stattfinden wird ein ganz cooles Projekt, nämlich der Hacktrain. Wir hatten so was vor ein paar Jahren schon mal auch für den Kongress. Das sind auch die gleichen Leute, die das machen. Das ist quasi ein speziell zur Anreise zu dieser Veranstaltung gemieteter Zug. Von, oh Gott, dass ich jetzt mal keinen Fehler mache, RHIB steht glaube ich für rein hessische Eisenbahnen. Das ist so ein Privatzug und die düsen so quer durch Deutschland. Das ist gleich nochmal die korrekte Uhr durchsagen. Ich will jetzt nichts Falsches sagen. wiki.whatthehack.org ist eigentlich gerade so das Sammelbecken, wo sich alle Informationen finden, darunter eben auch die Informationen zu diesem Hacktrain. Wer da mitfahren will, sollte sich ganz schleunigst anmelden, weil die zwar viele Voranmeldungen hatten, aber die konkreten Buchungen fallen jetzt ein bisschen aus. Wenn ein bisschen wochenendlich alles zusammen ist, ist das Projekt etwas gefährdet, aber das wird wohl werden. Ja, das ist sozusagen unser Ausblick auf die Veranstaltungswelt. Das nächste, was dann mir in den Sinn käme, ist der Kongressende des Jahres, aber das noch ein bisschen Platz.
So was wir mit der Musik machen, ist hinreichend grotesk. Wir distribuieren einen Podcast über UKW. Obwohl, wer kann das schon von sich behaupten? Normalerweise machen sie es ja andersrum. Also die BBC, ja gut, das was die UKW machen, ist Podcast raushauen. Aber wir sind eben die Avangard.
Sollte man vielleicht noch mal kurz erwähnen, was sich hinter diesem Begriff versteckt. Podcast ist ja ein recht junges Phänomen. Ist eine Mischung aus iPod und Broadcast basiert auf diesem doch recht durch Webblogs sehr populären RSS Format. Also was man halt so leicht abonnieren kann, um eben leicht Webseiten zu lesen, die eben so diese Blogstruktur haben. Da ist ja so ein finniger Ex-MTV-Moderator, dieser Adam Curry, drauf gekommen. Na ja, da könnte man jetzt nur noch so eine kleine Erweiterung mit einbauen. Also benutzen, die war schon mal spezifiziert, aber jetzt ja halt einfach benutzt. Und dann eine kleine Software geschrieben, die dann quasi automatisch mp3s über RSS ausliefert. Und im Endeffekt sieht es so aus, man abonniert quasi so eine Quelle von Audioaufzeichnungen und die wird eben automatisch gleich auf den iPod mit drauf geschrieben, so dass man quasi das nachts laufen lässt. Und morgens hat man immer schon wieder neue Radioberichte, Musiksendungen, kurze Snippets, was auch immer, der ganze Wahnsinn. Das Netz ist voll mit solchen Kram. Es gibt eben auch sehr schöne DJ-Mixes, wie zum Beispiel das, was wir jetzt gerade hören, von DJ ZynFlight hier aus Berlin. Und er macht dazu komplette Mixer, mp3, hoher Qualität, 192 Kbps. Und das fällt jetzt in einer neuen Version von diesem iTunes hier einfach so rein. Einfach einfacher kann man Radio gar nicht hören.
Chaosradio 103 ist, was ihr hört und eigentlich, und damit fangen wir mal an, dachte ich, geht es um User Interfaces, also Benutzerschnittstellen heute Abend.
Ja, User Interface, das ist ja auch so eins von diesen von diesen gedehnten Begriffen, wo sich immer so recht keiner was darunter vorstellen kann und tatsächlich ist auch ein weites Feld. Das ist uns auch selbst dann wieder mal bewusst geworden, als wir uns vor ein paar Wochen erst einmal getroffen haben zu dem Thema und versucht haben, das überhaupt mal so auszuloten, was denn jetzt eigentlich das Relevante ist, was man so erzählen soll. Da kommt man dann so dermaßen von Hundertsten und Tausendsten. Das haben wir schon ganz gut sortiert bekommen. Was wir heute tun wollen, ist, wir wollen erst mal so ein bisschen die Geschichte der User Interfaces durchrattern und mal schauen, was sich da so parallel entwickelt hat, also die Entwicklung der Computertechnologie und dann eben auch parallel in diese User Interfaces und was das für interessante soziale Auswirkungen gehabt hat. Und im Laufe der Sendung wollen wir dann eben auch noch ein paar andere Aspekte kommen, wie zum Beispiel halt die modernen Graphical User Interfaces, die wir heute alle benutzen, mehrheitlich, aber eben auch so spezielle Fragestellungen, die sich daraus ergeben, wie zum Beispiel Usability, das ist ja schon kurz erwähnt worden, damit L mit ihrem Projekt, mit dem Open Usability Org, oder auch Accessibility, so ein anderes Buzzword in diesem Zusammenhang, was es eben vor allem Leuten mit Behinderungen oder sonstigen Einschränkungen in der täglichen Benutzung mit Computern einfacher machen soll, oder überhaupt erst möglich machen soll, mit Computern zu arbeiten.
Barrierefreiheit.
Barrierefreiheit, Zugehörigkeit.
Vielleicht hört ihr der eine oder die andere, wie auch immer, körperbehindert, sehbehindert, oder auch, was weiß ich, körperbehindert zu, und hätte Lust später mal zu erklären, wie es so ist am Gerät, ob es Spaß am Gerät gibt oder es eher kein Spaß ist. 0331 70 97 1 70 0 ist unsere Nummer. Wir werden später sicherlich nochmal ausführlich dann auch über Accessibility, also Barrierefreiheit von User Interfaces reden wollen.
Schön schräg, schön schräger Sound, wie Schmorks. Bevor wir es vergessen, wir haben natürlich auch noch so ein paar digitale Schnittstellen in diese Sendung hinein. Zum Beispiel, ich hoffe sie läuft, die E-Mail Adresse 103, Chaosradio ccc.de. Da könnt ihr euer Feedback hinschicken nach der Sendung, vielleicht nicht unbedingt während der Sendung, da kriegen wir das jetzt nicht gelesen. Wer Lust hat mit anderen Leuten zu diskutieren, da gibt es den Chaosradio IRC-Kanal auf dem FreeNode Netzwerk. Es gibt da ja so verschiedene. Da wird schon ganz heiß diskutiert. Und schon viele Leute sind online, das ist gut. Ich versuche hier so ein bisschen mit reinzuschauen, aber wir werden da nicht groß diskutieren können. Aber das ist auf jeden Fall eure Möglichkeit hier, euer User Interface zu unserer Radiosendung zu haben. Tja, da fangen wir an. Am Anfang war das Bit.
Okay, aus der Nummer kommt es jetzt mal alleine wieder raus.
Am Anfang war das Bit. Die Erfindung des Computers war ja vor allem erstmal die Erfindung der Reduktion, die Möglichkeit zu rechnen, Computer rechnen, zahlen, tralala, mit einer elektrischen Maschine. Das ging halt vor allem dadurch, dass man eben diese 01 Nummer erfunden hat. Man hat also einfach andere Zahlensysteme verwendet, als wir das heute tun. Wir haben 10 Finger, benutzen das Dezimalsystem. Der Computer hat im Prinzip nur zwei Finger. Oder eigentlich nur einen. Der ist halt entweder an oder aus. Deswegen zählt er mit Nullen und Einsen. Dementsprechend war die Maschine einfach am Anfang auch gestrickt. Um einem Computer zu sagen, was er tun soll, und darum geht es ja eigentlich bei User Interfaces, beziehungsweise auch für den Computer natürlich, einem zu sagen, was er denn nun getan hat, muss man in irgendeiner Form eine gemeinsame Sprache finden. Und am Anfang war natürlich diese gemeinsame Sprache erstmal die Sprache der Computer. Das heißt, Programmierer haben diese Maschinen programmiert, indem sie irgendwelche Hebeschalter gedrückt haben, Klack hoch, klack runter, jedes einzelne Bit einzeln angeschaltet, eine Taste gedrückt, zack, das ist jetzt deine nächste Instruktion. Und dann wird dich in einem minutenlangen oder stundenlangen Vorgang vielleicht auch das Programm da so reingetappert, weil es halt nichts anderes gab. Keine Terminals, keine Tastaturen, gar Mäuse, da mag man gar nicht dran denken. Es gab noch nicht mal Bildschirme, sondern es gab einfach nur so Schalter und für die Rückmeldung Blinkenlites. Also kleine, lustige, blinkende Lämpchen, wie man sie aus vielen Filmen kennt, die damals durchaus noch eine konkrete Funktion hatten. Also irgendwann war das ja nur noch so ein Gimmick. Aber um eben mit der Maschine zu arbeiten, war das eben ganz wichtig. Das waren im Prinzip die ersten User Interfaces. Lächerlich, dass heutzutage so zu nennen.
Du willst mir sagen, dass die Blinkenlites auf dem WarGames-Rechner nur Gimmick waren?
Ja, auf dem WarGames-Rechner waren die nur Gimmick. Das war halt nur, falls jemand von der Verwaltung kommt. Unsere neue Maschine, die Maschine mit dem Ding. Ja, haben wir schon erwähnt, dass wir auch Radiostreams haben?
Haben wir?
Haben wir.
Buffering, also wir haben einen, der buffert?
Wir podcasten zwar noch nicht, das ist ein Versäumnis, das wissen wir. Mal schauen, was wir da noch tun können. Ist ja eigentlich gar nicht so schwierig, muss man nur mal machen.
Der ABW podcastet insgesamt nicht.
Aber wir streamen immerhin schon seit ewigen Generatoren und das steht alles auf Chaosradio.ccc.de, falls ihr jetzt irgendwelche Leute irgendwo im Chat habt, die das gerne empfangen wollen, aber gerade keine passende Frequenz zur Hand haben. Ja, ich mach einfach mal weiter.
Du machst ja sonst keiner weiter.
Und klapper irgendwie durch. Ja, Sven schaut mich ganz erwartungsvoll an. Naja, eigentlich genau. Ähm, also die, irgendwann sind sie halt, irgendwann waren die Maschinen dann so groß und die Aufgaben so weit gesteckt, dass man eben A, sehr viel Ausgabe hatte, auf der anderen Seite dann eben auch, weil man diese ganzen Ausgaben auch wieder reinfüttern wollte, eingaben gehabt haben. Ich bin mir jetzt nicht so richtig hundertprozentig sicher, was in den 50er Jahren so die primären Anwendungen waren, außer den industriellen und wissenschaftlichen, aber sowas wie Einwohner-Erfassung war da auf jeden Fall auch schon ein Thema und dazu brauchte man halt Daten rein. Genau, bloß die Datenbanken von damals waren halt noch nicht wirklich auf Festplatten oder so, weil Festplatten waren nicht erfunden, schweige denn irgendwie Floppy Discs, RAM war damals, waren so große quadratische Metallringen-Konstruktionen, wo man irgendwie ganz stolz war, wenn man da mal 30 Bits reinbekommen hat. Also das war halt alles überhaupt nicht. Speichern war einfach etwas, was die Maschinen am Anfang gar nicht gut konnten. Die konnten eigentlich immer nur für einen kurzen Moment in ihren Registern das vorhalten, was sie eben gerade für die Verarbeitung brauchten und auch so das ganze Auswerten war einfach eher so ein automatisiertes Durchblättern. Und das populärste ein Ausgabemedium wurde dann die Lochkarte. Das ist also einfach so ein Stück Karton mit vielen Löchern drin oder eben auch nicht. Und jedes Loch oder nicht Loch repräsentierte eben die entsprechende 0 oder 1 für einen Datensatz.
Da wo man vorher den Kippschalter umgelegt hat, stand man jetzt ein Loch in das Papier und da wo man ihn nicht umgelegt hat, enthielt kein Loch und so kamen dann diese ganze Einstellungen, die man vorher an irgendeiner Schalterfront gemacht hat. Wiederum an einer Schalterfront machen aber das Abspeichern auf einer Lochkarte. Und wenn man dann sein Programm auf dieser Lochkarte fertig hat, dann läuft man damit zum Rechenzentrum, gibt es da quasi an der Tür ab. Die lassen einen natürlich nicht da rein. Und die füttern das dann irgendwann, wenn dann halt die Zeit gekommen ist, jetzt für diesen Programmierer ein bisschen Rechenzeit bereitzustellen, in den Computer rein. Und wenn man Glück hat, kann man vielleicht am nächsten Tag oder nächste Woche eine Lochkarte wiederum abholen, wo dann das Ergebnis reingesteunst wird.
Und da sagt noch mal einer, wird von Entschleunigung.
Das User Interface IRC-Chat weist mich darauf hin, dass wir wohl offensichtlich noch keinen wirklich kompletten Mitschnitt der Radiosendung 101 haben. Und ich soll doch mal fragen, ob da draußen jemand einen hat. Wenn er hat, schickt das mal an uns. Unsere Chaos Radio Adresse, dann können wir das beheben. Ich weiß, dass mehrere Leute mitschneiden. Das wird sicherlich sicher auftreiben lassen. Ja, wo waren wir denn? Wir waren bei den doch Karten, bei den tollen doch Karten. Ja, ja, super, also ich meine, es ist ein echt tolles System. Es ist sozusagen gleichzeitig Eingabe als auch Ausgabe. Und hat sich auch echt leicht verhalten.
Habt ihr euch auf derselben Lochkarte? Nee, natürlich nicht, aber das wäre praktisch.
Na ja, gut, also wenn du halt ein Bit ändern willst, dann geht das so von 0 auf 1. Also ich weiß jetzt gar nicht, was ist denn eigentlich die 0 und was ist denn eigentlich die 1 bei der Lochkarte?
Gute Frage, hat irgendjemand schon wirklich mal Lochkarten benutzt?
Vielleicht weiß es ja jemand, was ist bei der Lochkarte die 0 und was ist bei der Lochkarte die 1? Wir bitten um Aufklärung unter 0331 7097110.
Genau, oder im Chat.
Oder im Chat. Sag nochmal, wo der ist.
Hier auf meinem Bildschirm.
Und was steht auf Ihrem Bildschirm?
Da steht noch nix irgendwie. Ja, also entweder 0 oder 1, auf jeden Fall, man verwendet halt dasselbe Medium. So, ich meine heutzutage hast du Tastaturen, Bildschirme, es ist definitiv nicht das gleiche. Aber das ist nur eine kleine Spielart. Diese Lochkarte hat sich verdammt lange gehalten, weil es eben auch lange Zeit nicht wirklich ernsthafte Alternativen gab. Aber vor allem zementierte halt die Lochkarte das totale Abwesenheit von Interaktivität. Also auch gerade muss ich vorstellen, auch Programmierer haben ja so gearbeitet. Wenn dann irgendwie an so einer Uni so ein großer Mainframe war, der war dann von AWM, dann waren da so ein paar elitiere Schlipse, die da so herumgelaufen sind. Und das war dann sozusagen ihre Kirche. Da durfte man dann auch nicht so ohne weiteres rein. Also auch diese ganze Ablehnung, die sich ja noch so ein bisschen die 80er Jahre rein, so gegen IBM als den großen Bösewicht, bis Microsoft das irgendwie in der öffentlichen Wahrnehmung irgendwann mal abgelöst hat. Das zehrt vor allem auch sehr aus dieser ganzen 50er- 60er- 70er-Jahre-Zeit, wo einfach IBM sich von so einer typo Typewriter-Bude zu dem Computerriesen schlechthin hochgearbeitet hat. Und da gab es halt einfach rechtens drin, das war dann halt im Wesentlichen IBM. Und wenn ein Programmierer was programmieren wollte, muss er seine Stapel-Lochkarten da irgendwie abwerfen und dann haben die das so über Nacht da rein gefüttert und am nächsten Tag durfte er sich das Ergebnis abholen. Also so mit interaktiven Debugging, wie man das so heute kennt, um seine Softwaremaß zu schneidern, hat das natürlich herzlich wenig zu tun.
Wenn man dann einen Syntax Error hatte, dann durfte man vielleicht am nächsten Abend dann noch mal wiederkommen mit einem neuen Stapel Lochkarten.
Ja, hat aber den Vorteil, dass man zu Hause programmieren konnte und nicht jeder zu Hause einen eigenen Rechner gebraucht hat. Also das wäre halt nicht sein eigenes Gemüse.
Ich muss noch ein bisschen stunzen.
Wenn Fritz in Neukölln, dann 102, 6.
Eine nach der Welt.
Fritz Info.
Heute Nacht wird's richtig wolkig. Stellenweise kann es sogar etwas Regen geben bei Temperaturen zwischen 10 und 15 Grad. Morgen wolkiger als heute. Es soll aber bis zum Abend trocken bleiben. Das heißt so viel wie sagt hinterher nicht. Wir hätten euch nicht gewarnt. Die Höchsttemperaturen morgen zwischen 21 und 26 Grad. Und die Meldungen mit Gerald Kötterheinrich.
Die beiden in Afghanistan getöteten Bundeswehrsoldaten sind nach Deutschland überführt worden. Eine Luftwaffenmaschine mit den Särgen an Bord landete am Abend auf dem militärischen Teil des Kölner Flughafens. Die Soldaten waren vor vier Tagen im Nordas-Osten Afghanistans getötet worden, als beim Verladen von Munition drei Lastwagen explodierten. Das Verfahren um die Vertrauensfrage im Bundestag stößt auch bei SPD-Politikern auf starke Bedenken. Die Bundestagsabgeordnete Hoffmann will deshalb das Bundesverfassungsgericht in Karlsruhe anrufen. Sie habe Zweifel, ob die unechte Vertrauensfrage von Bundeskanzler Schröder mit dem Grundgesetz übereinstimme. Schröder selbst will sich am Freitag bei der Vertrauensfrage der Stimme enthalten. Das Arbeitslosengeld II in Ostdeutschland soll auf Westniveau angehoben werden. Der Hartz-IV-Umbotsrat schlug in seinem Zwischenbericht vorkünftig einheitlich 345 Euro zu zahlen. Wirtschaftsminister Clement will die Empfehlung umsetzen. Der Mörder der Kinder Lefke und Felix muss lebenslang ins Gefängnis. Das Landgericht Stade ordnete außerdem noch eine Sicherungsverwahrung an. Der Angeklagte hatte zugegeben, die beiden acht Jahre alten Kinder entführt, missbraucht und ermordet zu haben. Zum Sport, das deutsche Fußball-Nationalteam, hat das Spiel um Platz drei beim Confederation Cup in Deutschland, weil er übrigens gegen Mexiko mit 4 zu 3 nach Verlängerung gewonnen. Das entscheidende Tor für Deutschland schloss dabei Michael Balak. Im Moment läuft noch das Endspiel. Dabei führt Brasilien gegen Argentinien kurz vor Schluss mit 4 zu 1. Der Verkehr Fritz mit zwei Meldungen. Die erste A12 Berlin Richtung Frankfurt Oder. 5 Kilometer Stau zwischen Frankfurt Süd und dem Grenzübergang Frankfurt. Da hat es einen Unfall gegeben. Der Verkehr wird an der Abfahrt Frankfurt West abgeleitet. Die letzte freie Ausfahrt ist im Moment Mühlrose. Und Stadtverkehr Berlin Tiergarten. Wegen des Live-Aid-Konzerts am Samstag gibt es schon heute die ersten Sperrungen. Betroffen ist die Straße des 17. Juni zwischen Entlastungsstraße und Großen Stern. Ansonsten keine aktuellen Meldungen. Gute Fahrt.
Vielen Dank, Gerald Kötterheinrich. Drei Minuten nach halb elf.
Jeder kann hinkommen und so seinen MP3s abspielen.
Scheißegal, was für ein Style.
Wir wollen hören, was andere hören.
Coole Musik, finde ich total cool, das Konzert.
Ihr bringt eure digitalen Musikplayer mit eurer Lieblingsmusik in den Fritz Club. Ihr bildet zu zweit ein DJ-Team. Ihr bekommt eine Viertelstunde Zeit und bestellt, wonach die anderen tanzen.
Die Fritz Ei Party.
Die Party für MP3s Musik.
Ihr seid die DJs. Und diesmal verlosen wir unter allen, die vorbeikommen, zwei niegelnageneue MP3-Player. Die Fritz Ei Party. Kommenden Freitag ab 23 Uhr im Fritz Club im Postbahnhof Berlin. Preis der Musik.
Ich bin ein Künstler, ich bin ein Künstler.
Chaos Radio 103 und User Interfaces ist unser Thema.
Das User Interface funktioniert perfekt. Also ich weiß jetzt, was die 1 und was die 0 ist.
Ah, auf der Lochkarte.
Genau, und zwar die Löcher sind die Einsen und zwar unter anderem, also was daraus folgt oder was man zu tun hat, ist das Delete, das Zeichen Delete ist irgendwie 7f oder 7 Einsen sozusagen, denn mit Delete kann man sozusagen auch irgendwie Löcher dann noch stanzen, wenn eine andere Zahl da stand. Also wenn man sozusagen ein Delete Zeichen speichert, dann macht man halt alles auf Einsen und egal, welche Zahl davor stand auf der Lochkarte, danach ist halt alles Einsen. Toll, was? Aber was war denn das jetzt hier mit dieser iParty, was wir da gerade gehört haben?
Eine ganz witzige Idee, die sie bei uns im ersten Stock entwickelt haben.
Ja, ist das eure Forschungsabteilung?
Das sind die, die den Buffer freien Replay erfunden haben. Ne, die Fritz-Forschungsabteilung hat sich das ausgedacht. Wir haben das schon ein paar Mal gemacht. Du dimmst deinen iPod natürlich oder MP3-Player deines geringsten Misstrauens. Du gehst in den Fritz-Club und sagst hier, ich will auflehnen. Suchst dir noch einen zweiten, weil du brauchst ja einen zweiten Player. Du willst ja mischen. Suchst ja am besten noch einen Kumpel oder irgendwen Fremdes. Komm mal mit, wir legen jetzt auf. Ja, dann stellst du dich da hin, kannst eine Viertelstunde auflegen. Und wenn du Glück hast, tanzen die Leute. Oder du lernst, wie man einen Laden leer spielt.
Aha, und was heißt für einen...
Das ist auch so ein Dirt.
Ein Dirt?
Na ja, so ein Puppe, wenn man total schlecht war, wie in dieser komischen Fernsehshow. Ja, wo man so 15 Sekunden hat, sein Können zu beweisen. Und wenn man es nicht geschafft hat, die anderen zu überzeugen, wird man rausgekippt.
Ist das nicht hier diese Sat1 morgens, wo die immer so schlussig sind? Aber wo erkennst du das dann?
Ich weiß nicht.
Hörensagen.
Hörensagen, genau richtig, Hörensagen.
Einspruch, Hörensagen. 0331 70 97 110 ist die Nummer der Fritzwortlein, die im Idealfall dazu führt, dass ihr hier in der Sendung gehört werdet im Chaosradio. Und Burak hat angerufen, er wollte auch noch ein bisschen was zu Lochkarten erzählen.
Wir hören dich, leg mal los. Was hast du zu erzählen, zu Lochkarten?
Ich kenn zwar meine Informationen nicht auf erster Hand, sondern auf zweiter Hand, da ich gerade 22 bin und mit Lochkarten eigentlich wenig zu tun, allerdings muss ich dazu sagen, da wurden keine Bits einzeln gesetzt, sondern durch die Löcher wurden direkt die Buchstaben kodiert.
Soweit ich weiß.
Wie meinst du das genau?
Also, wenn man ein Loch gesetzt hat, dann hat man einen Buchstaben oder ein Zeichen gesetzt und kein Bit einzeln.
Ich glaub, es war Hexa-Code, oder? Also irgendwie.
Der guckt mich nicht an.
Doch, doch, ich hab hier eine Lochkarte zu Hause. Wie soll denn das gehen? Ich weiß es nicht mehr genau. Ihr seid die Entwickler.
Also ich weiß nicht ganz genau, was du da wie rum verstanden hast, aber es ist ja so, wenn man ein... Ein Loch kann ja nur... Also Bit, die Abkürzung... Bit ist ja eine Abkürzung für binary digit, also binäres Zeichen, also 0 oder 1. Und genau das ist ja Loch oder nicht Loch. Und was du meinst, ist, dass halt immer 7 Löcher in Gruppen ein Zeichen ergeben haben.
Also ich kann mich erinnern, eine Lochkarte gesehen zu haben, wo dann Buchstaben drauf waren, die einzeln aufgestanzt wurden.
Dann ist das aber jetzt nicht das, was wir mit Lochkarte meinen, sondern noch irgendein anderes lustiges.
Gab es sicherlich auch ein paar Lochkartengenerationen, so wie Spidersketten oder Festplatten.
Gut, aber unter Lochkarte an sich versteht man halt dieses binäres System, mit dem halt auch alle möglichen Tanzorgeln und so weiter gesteuert werden, teilweise ja auch heute noch. Und es gibt auch einen sehr schönen Artikel übrigens in der Wikipedia. Ich hab auch gleich nochmal nachgeschlagen. Da ist das alles ganz schön erklärt und ich hatte auch in etwa recht. Für die Volkszählung wurde das ursprünglich mal eingesetzt. So Hollerit-Maschinen sozusagen. Und so funktioniert das. Aber danke für deine Rückmeldung.
Ja, noch eine kleine Bitte. Die Adresse, wo man euren Chat erreichen kann.
Vielleicht nochmal erwähnen, weil irgendwie weder Wikipedia noch eure Webseite kann ich das finden.
Das ist natürlich ein Versehen. Ich dachte, das steht da. Also IRC, und zwar geht ihr einfach auf den Server irc.freenode.net und dort in den Kanal Chaosradio. Tja, man drückt sich nicht immer verständlich aus. Also auch da haben wir wieder die User Interface Problematik. So, naja. Aber Lochkarten und so, das ist ja alles altes Zeug. Und wie wir schon gehört haben, heutzutage benutzt es eigentlich kein Mensch mehr. Man hat das vielleicht noch irgendwo rumliegen. Ich glaube, ich habe auch noch irgendwelche Lochkarten bei mir in meinem Keller verscharrt. Aber ich lese die nicht jeden Tag. Später gab es dann, also es gab dann eine ganz interessante Entwicklung. Weil am Anfang war es natürlich auch so, man hatte erst mal genug damit zu tun, die Computer als solche überhaupt erst mal zum Laufen zu bekommen. Die Rechenkapazitäten, die damals vorhanden waren, wirken ja heutzutage noch lächerlich. Also alles, was IBM, glaube ich, 30 Jahre zusammen gebaut hat, bringt nicht genug Rechenkapazität zusammen wie eine Digital-Uhr heute. Und irgendwann gab es dann auch diese Vermischung mit der Telekommunikation. Es gab ja dieses frühe Telex-System und es gab Schreibmaschinen. Und dann gab es elektrische Schreibmaschinen und dann gab es eben dann auch diese Fernschreiber.
Telex ist irgendwie quasi die Schreibmaschine auf der einen Seite und der Drucker auf der anderen Seite. Und dann nimmt man das beides auseinander und macht ein langes Kabel dazwischen und kann dann eben fernschreiben.
Genau, ein Fernschreiber. Tele-Type heißt das da. Genau, und das war natürlich dann quasi schon digitale Datenübertragung mit dem Ziel des Druckens. Also nur auf der einen Seite eintippen, auf der anderen Seite ausgeben, IO. Also quasi ein einfaches User Interface. Diese Maschinen wurden dann zunehmend auch an den Rechner gestöpselt, weil man konnte halt prima damit ausdrucken. Das ist natürlich schon mal ganz andere Geschichte als eine Blockkarte, weil es ist halt lesbar für den Menschen. An der Stelle haben wir also sozusagen auch ein neues, jungen Interface. Man kann halt in der Sprache des Menschen schreiben. Und die Tastatur ist natürlich auch etwas, wo der Mensch eben drauf tippen kann und dann in der Sprache des Menschen quasi mit dem Rechner redet. Und so hat sich dann eben das Prinzip des Druckerterminals herausgebildet, dass man eben mit dem Rechner durch Tastatur gearbeitet hat. Und der Rechner hat dann halt vor der Nase Sachen ausgegeben. So muss man sich das vorstellen. Also wie das heute auf dem Bildschirm läuft, lief es halt damals direkt auf Papier, weil Bildschirm gab es nicht. Also Kartonstrahlröhre war einfach noch nicht so verbreitet oder fands sich einfach noch nicht an so einem technologischen Punkt, wo man das eben so mal problemlos zur Anzeige von digitalen Informationen hätte benutzen können.
Aber mit den Tastaturen von damals schlagen wir uns eigentlich heute auch immer noch rum. Da hat sich eigentlich nicht viel getan.
Der mechanische Hub ist ein bisschen anders.
Aber so dieses ganze Konzept, man gibt irgendwas ein in ein Gerät, was eigentlich ein Fernschreiber ist, das taucht eigentlich immer noch auf. Das sieht man heutzutage noch auf der Kommandozeile. Wenn man irgendwie Enter drückt, das ist irgendwie ein Return und das ist einfach das, wo früher so der Wagenrücklauf war. Mit den Codes und auch der Tastatur-Anordnung von damals bedienen wir eigentlich heute noch unsere Computer.
Du tust es zumindest, ne? Ich eigentlich auch, aber nicht unbedingt jeder. Die meisten benutzen natürlich den Mausturm.
Spracheingabe, das ist eigentlich mit Spracheingabe funktioniert. Das ist nur user-seitig natürlich.
Spracheingabe, es gibt jedes Jahr irgendjemand, der der Meinung ist, man müsste es jetzt bald mal haben. Einerseits hat es immer noch technische Probleme, dass es einfach nicht funktioniert. Es funktioniert in bestimmten Umgebungen, unter bestimmten Bedingungen, was weiß ich, im Auto oder so, mit dem Handy, Telefonnummern aufrufen und sowas geht. Das geht aber auch für dich immer nur dann, wenn man echt alleine ist, weil man wird ja blöd, wenn Leute einem dabei zuschauen, wie man sich mit dem Computer unterhält. Das fühle ja sogar ich mich bekloppt.
Wie es bei mir ist, also Laptop, Trackpad, Tastatur, wobei ich hier am meisten auf das rote Nupsi von IBM stehe. Hat das eigentlich einen Namen?
Knubbel.
Ich dachte Nupsi. Bei mir heißt der Knubbel Nupsi, aber du kommst ja auch aus Süddeutschland.
Welchen Namen hat denn das Ding noch gleich?
Ich habe keine Ahnung, Nupsi. Wie heißt denn das rote Nupsi bei IBM? Knubbel ist auf jeden Fall besser.
Wir kommen jetzt so langsam auch in diesen anderen Bereich. Die Tastatur war erfunden schon durch die Schreibmaschine. Und auch dieses komische Tastaturlayout, das wir heute haben, ist im Prinzip durch die mechanischen Bedingungen einer Schreibmaschine definiert gewesen. Also wer sich schon immer mal gewundert hat, warum jetzt ein Buchstabe genau da ist und da und warum das nicht alphabetisch oder sonst irgendwas ist, sondern so bunt durcheinander. Soweit ich weiß, ist die Anordnung eben einfach so, dass man die Tasten, die häufig im Wechsel benutzt werden, möglichst weit auseinander sind, also dass diese Hebel sich nicht verfangen. Man kennt das, wenn man zwei Tasten drückt, die eben so zwei Hebel gleichzeitig bei der Schreibmaschine bewegen, die nebeneinander sind, dann verfangen die sich.
Wer mal eine mechanische Schreibmaschine noch benutzt, der kennt das. Man darf nicht zwei Tasten gleichzeitig drücken oder fast gleichzeitig.
Genau, aber umso weiter sie auseinander sind in dem ganzen mechanischen Geflecht, umso schneller kann man tippen. Deswegen ist es dahingehend optimiert, dass es sich nicht schnell verfängt, verklemmt oder was auch immer. Es gibt auch andere, also das ist natürlich so eine Einschränkung, die manche Leute nicht hinnehmen. Es gibt alternative Keyboard-Layouts, also abgesehen davon, dass jedes Land so seine eigene Variante hat, das kennen wir ja. Gibt es ein Keyboard-Layout unter dem Namen Dvorak? Ich bin mir gar nicht sicher, ob ich das richtig ausspreche.
Ich vermute, es heißt Dvorak.
Aber vielleicht finden wir ja sogar jemanden da draußen, der so ein Keyboard-Layout benutzt. Weil ich weiß, es gibt Leute auch bei uns im Club übrigens, die das irgendwie verwenden. Ich tue das nicht und das Layout ist anders. Also wenn irgendjemand von euch ein Dvorak Keyboard-Layout benutzt, dann würden wir sehr gerne darüber hören und ihr ruft uns an unter der Telefonnummer.
03317797110. Chaosradio 103 auf Fritz und User Interface ist unser Thema. Wo waren wir stehen? Bei Dvorak Dvorak DVORK, tastert du?
Ja, ja, ich suche gerade eben, es heißt wohl Dvorak.
Dvorak?
Ja, wenn ich hier gerade laut Wikipedia heiße, ist es wohl Dvorak, aber ich bin da auch.
Wer hat das überhaupt so benannt, dass man nicht 100% weiß, wie es heißt?
Der junge Mann war einfach einer der Führenden in dieser Kommission, die das entwickelt hat. Der hieß einfach so an. Wie heißt er? August Dvorak halt. Und vermute mal, ich weiß nicht ganz genau, kann man gleich mal gucken. Steht natürlich alles in der Wikipedia. Es steht da ja alles drin. Ja, das ist ein Amerikaner. Und die haben sich richtig Gedanken gemacht über die Physiologie der Hände und wie man halt so tippt und wie die Häufigkeit von Buchstaben ist. Und dahingehend eben das Tastaturlayout optimiert. Das ist ja eigentlich auch ein interessanter Ansatz, aber es war dann halt in gewisser Hinsicht schon zu spät.
Das hat sich nicht durchgesetzt, wahrscheinlich, wie du hier gerade in der Pause schon mal gesagt hast, dass jetzt noch mich umgewöhnen auf ein anderes Tastaturlayout. Das geht ja gar nicht.
Nee, das geht gar nicht, glaube ich. Aber es ist wahnsinnig schwer, glaube ich, einfach weil das Ö ist eben da, wo es ist.
Aus reiner Bequemlichkeit benutzen wir jetzt immer noch dieses Layout, was für die Schreibmaschinen optimiert wurde und nicht für den Benutzer.
Also nicht nur die Leute sind da reingewachsen, sondern auch die Programme. Also ich habe hier gerade so eine schöne Diskussion gehabt. Das kann ich gut nachvollziehen, wenn man so unter Unix arbeitet. Und ich kenne das halt auch noch. Ich habe früher meinen ersten Unix-Computer hatte ich nicht bei mir zu Hause, sondern ich hatte nur so eine OLED-DOS-Schüssel mit einem einfachen Terminal-Programm und habe halt meinen Unix-Computer quasi in einer anderen Firma über Telefonleitungen, über ein Modem benutzt. Und zwar über ein sehr, sehr, sehr langsames Modem. Wir sprechen von 300 Bit pro Sekunde. Das ist 30 Bytes pro Sekunde. Und daher mal mit eurem DSL-Anschluss vergleichen. Ist schon ein bisschen was anderes. Und da kommst du so in Probleme rein, die man sich gar nicht so richtig vorstellen kann. Also zum Beispiel, wenn ich einen Editor benutze und der Unix sehr verbreitet zu, zum Beispiel dieser VI, so ein ganz simpler Text-Editor. So Cursor hoch, links, rechts, oben, unten. Man kann ein bisschen was ändern, also nothing fancy. Dann hab ich zum Beispiel nie die Cursor-Tasten benutzt, obwohl ich eigentlich welche hatte, weil wenn ich eine Cursor-Taste nutze, dann wird nicht ein Zeichen drüber gesendet, sondern drei, weil das sozusagen ein sogenannter Escape-Code ist. Denn Cursor-Tasten gehören einfach nicht zum Standard-Zeichensatz und das muss halt in irgendeiner Form gesagt werden, so jetzt kommt was anderes und zwar und dann noch mal zwei Zeichen. Das dauert erst mal dreimal so lange. Und häufig hatte man eben auch einfach Übertragungsfehler, und zwar so richtig häufig, vor allem wenn man Akustik-Cobbler benutzt hat, dann durfte man ja auch nicht mal husten. Und dann kann es einem halt schon mal schnell das Zeichen in der Mitte weghauen und dann wird eben aus so einer Sequenz, die eigentlich Cursor hoch bedeutet, was ganz anderes oder vielleicht zerstört es auch noch irgendwas. Also ganz furchtbar. Deswegen benutze ich das nie und hab dann eben das auch so mit Tastatur, also mit den normalen Buchstaben benutze. Jk hoch runter, hl links rechts. Das habe ich irgendwie total im Blut. Und hier meinte auch einer, er hätte auch mal Dvorag irgendwie versucht zu benutzen, aber hat es dann eben sein gelassen, weil er eben sein irgendwie ein nicht mehr benutzen konnte. Was denn? Ich kann euch nur raten, in die Chatreihe zu schauen. Da wird wirklich sehr umfangreich das ganze Thema hier nochmal quer diskutiert. Das kann ich alles gar nicht aufnehmen. Auf jeden Fall hat sich Dvorak nicht durchgesetzt, aber es gibt da so eine religiöse Clique, die macht das halt noch. Die haben solche Tastaturen und benutzen das und das wird auch nicht komplett aussterben. Aber es haben sich ja ganz andere User Interfaces durchgesetzt. Vor allem gab es ja dann auch irgendwann den Durchbruch der Maus oder auch des Checkballs oder des Checkpads oder eben des Checkpoints, wie sie alle heißen, aber die im Prinzip alle dasselbe bedeuten. Nämlich man steuert so ein Objekt, den Zeiger, über eine zweidimensionale Fläche und hat halt irgendein Gerät, was in der Lage ist eben direkt eine Bewegung der Hand, des Fingers, des Arms, zweidimensional auf den Computer zu übertragen.
Das ist auch schon ziemlich alt.
Uralt.
1968 wurde nicht etwa von Apple erfunden, wie viele denken, sondern von Doug Engelbart, der ein Gerät mit einer ganzen Menge verschiedenen Eingabemethoden entwickelt hatte und die Maus hatte sich eben durchgesetzt gegenüber anderen Dingen, wie zum Beispiel Lightpens, wo man eben direkt im Interface mit einem Lichtstift, der Mist, wo er angesetzt wird, in bestimmte Textsegmente reingehen kann. Die Maus war einfach so ein Kasten mit verschiedenen, mit zwei Rollen am Ende, einer vertikalen und einer horizontalen und damit konnte man eben durch die Gegend scrollen und wenn man sich ganz schnell irgendwo hin bewegen wollte, dann hat man die Maus einfach hochgehoben und mal kurz einen Schubs gegeben und sie dann wieder angehalten, wenn man dort war, wo man hin wollte. Also echt eine ganz schnelle Art und Weise sich zu bewegen, das heute mit den optischen Mäusen leider auch gar nicht mehr geht.
Ich hätte mich gerade in dem Moment gefragt, wie geht denn das eigentlich mit so einer optischen Maus? Aber ich glaube, wenn ich mir das erklären lasse, mache ich mich wieder lächerlich.
Tja, da müssen die Techniker wieder ran. Wie das mit der optischen Maus funktioniert.
Die optischen Maus, das ist ein ganz toller Fortschritt. Da ist halt einfach so ein kleiner Scanner drin. Da ist einerseits ein Lichtgeber und empfängt das Licht auch gleich wieder mit einem optischen Sensor. Im Prinzip ist das ein Scanner, das heißt, der scannt die Oberfläche. In einer sehr hohen Auflösung, ich weiß nicht genau wie fein, auf jeden Fall fein genug, dass er eben so die Mikrostrukturen der Oberfläche, Tisch, Maserung und so weiter, das ist optimal dafür, sieht er halt einfach die Veränderung und trägt quasi die Bewegung.
Maserung ist doch meistens gar nicht so gut, also wenn man eine starke Maserung auf dem Tisch hat, die sich nicht gerade bewegt, dann wird die Maus doch meistens abgelenkt.
Hängt vom Produkt ab, also ich hab da solche und solche, wie heißt es so schon? Jermail de Schmerverri, die ersten optischen Mäuse, die es gab, waren von Sun.
Ich glaube Sun hatte die, wir hatten die in der Uni und da brauchte man noch so ein spezielles Mauspad, wo halt so ein ganz feines Gitter aufgedruckt ist und die Maus hat halt quasi gesehen, wie viele Gitterstriche habe ich jetzt überfahren und das ist ein bisschen weiterentwickelt worden und ich glaube du brauchst aber immer noch irgendeine Struktur, also wenn du wirklich einen hochpolierten Tisch hast, dann wird die optische Maus einfach gar nicht funktionieren.
Die sind besser geworden, aber da ist noch was zu holen.
Ich bin ein Kunde. Ich bin ein Kunde. Ich bin ein Kunde. Ich bin ein Kunde. Ich bin ein Kunde. Ich bin ein Kunde. Ich bin ein Kunde.
Doch, Lichtgriffel war großartig.
Man musste zu oft zwischen Tastatur und Griffel, also die hatten ja auch schon eine Tastatur in diesem Layout, und man musste eben zu oft wechseln und dieser Wechsel hat zu viel Zeit gekostet.
Nein, da spricht die Usability Expertin. Da bin ich vor der Sendung extra ungewiesen worden.
Wir sprechen heute nur mit Binnen-I.
Auch wenn meine Stimme heute mal wieder etwas belegt ist, ich bin eine Frau.
Ich kenne weibliche Moderatoren, die würden sonst was dafür geben, um so eine Stimme zu haben.
Ich fand auf jeden Fall die Lichtgriffel total toll, weil die einfach interessante Spiele auch ermöglicht haben.
Die Ballerspiele wurden immer über den Fernseher gefasst.
Das sind aber die Joysticks, die dürfen wir vielleicht nicht vergessen.
Ja, genau, Spiele-Interfaces, da sind wir jetzt im Prinzip. Lichtgriffel ist allerdings auch so eine... Ich fände das total cool, weil das ist ja auch nur etwas, was völlig cyberspace-mäßig rüberkommt, wo man hält so einen Stift vor den Bildschirmen und dann weiß der Computer, wo man den hingehalten hat. Und da der Bildschirm überhaupt keine Kamera hat oder so, muss man sich einfach fragen, woher weiß er denn das eigentlich? Ich weiß nicht, ob das irgendwie eben so klar ist. Weißt du es? Was?
Entschuldigung, ich hab gerade auf den Bildschirm geguckt und mich nicht von der Kamera...
Also ein Lichtgriffel funktioniert so, dass man tatsächlich da auf dem Bildschirm drauf zeigt.
Weißt du, wie es funktioniert? Ich vermute mal, dass der irgendwie... Kann der Pixel messen? Also weiß der, welches Pixel er sich anguckt?
Naja, also der Clou ist, man benutzt ja... Also damals hat man halt in der Regel normale Röhrenmonitore benutzt. Die heißen technisch Kathodenstrahlröhre, weil da hinten eine Kathode ist und da kommt ein Strahl raus. Und der Bildschirminhalt entsteht dadurch, dass eben dieser eine Strahl von oben nach unten immer von links nach rechts abgelenkt, langsam nach unten geführt, jeden einzelnen Bildpunkt einmal anschießt. Das gibt aber nur einen Strahl. Das heißt, zu einem bestimmten Zeitpunkt zeigt dieser Strahl auch immer nur auf einen Pixel. Dieser Lichtgriffel hat nun eigentlich nichts anderes gemacht als diesen Heddigkeitsimpuls, der kurz flackert, den man so nicht sieht, weil es in dieser Phosphorschicht irgendwie untergeht und unser Auge auch nicht in der Lage ist, sowas wahrzunehmen. Aber dieser Lichtgriffel sieht man sehr wohl. Hat er diesen Lichtimpuls in dem Moment einfach durchgereicht an den Computer und der hat wiederum seinen Video-Baustein gefragt und hat gesagt, welchen Punkt hast du denn gerade aufgebaut? Damit weiß er ganz genau die Position.
Das ist aber auch so ein bisschen von hinten durch die Brust ins Auge, ne?
Aber volles Programm.
Kein Wunder, dass ich das nicht durchgesetzt habe.
Hat super funktioniert.
Die meiste Rechenzeit geht für den Lichtgriffel drauf. Aber es sieht unglaublich geil aus.
Tatsächlich ist das so ein Abfallprodukt, da muss man gar nicht für rechnen. Da muss man nur nachgucken, was er eh gerade weiß. Die alten Grafikchips waren einfach genauso gebaut, dass sie einfach so Zeile für Zeile aufgebaut haben. Und er wusste immer ganz genau, was er gerade liefert. Da gab es keine Buffer und tausende digitale Schnittstellen, ein bisschen Bildschirm und dann LCDs und jeder Pixel wird gleichzeitig angesteuert. Das war alles ganz einfach. Deswegen konnte man auch solche einfachen Sachen machen. Heute, beim LCD, würde so ein Lichtgriffel-Stich nicht mehr funktionieren.
Dann verkaufen wir den an irgendwelche... Es hat übrigens mal wieder jemand angerufen. 0331 77 97 110. Und das ist der Michael aus Stuttgart, oder der Nähe von Stuttgart.
Ja, aus der Nähe von Stuttgart.
Hallo Michael.
Hallo.
Ja, und zwar, ja Tastatur. Das ist so ein bisschen mein liebes Kind noch. Da möchte ich mich jetzt einfach mal hier öffentlich ein bisschen bei der Hersteller von Software beschweren. Leute, guckt mal bitte zu, dass ihr diese ganzen Tastaturkötzel auch immerhin noch weiter benutzt. Weil ich habe oft schon bei Software jetzt erlebt, dass das immer mehr wegfällt. Dass man einfach nur noch mit der Maus bedienen kann. Und das stört mich ziemlich.
Du hast das Gefühl, dass die Programme eigentlich nur noch auf Maus benutzen.
Ja, zum Beispiel bei mir in der Firma, ich bin in der EDV-Branche tätig, fühle mir ein neues ERP-System ein.
Was für ein System?
Ein ERP-System. Das ist ein Wirtschaftssystem. Und zwar, das sind ja Programme, wo man ziemlich viele Daten eingeben muss. Auch über die Tastatur. Jetzt ist es so, dass zum Beispiel, wenn man jetzt den Datensatz freigeben möchte, dann muss man die Maus benutzen. Das geht schon gar nicht mehr mit der Tastatur. Und das ist einfach dann, wenn ich dann wieder zum Maus greifen muss, dann geht einfach Zeit verloren.
Na ja, da sind wir auch wieder in der Accessibility, wo wir später hin wollten. Also das ist nicht nur ein Zeitproblem, das ist auch für Menschen mit Körperbehinderungen, die eben gar keine Maus verwenden können zum Beispiel. Dass die, wenn die eben über die Tastaturen nicht die gesamte Anwendung bedienen können, dass sie dann echt ein Problem haben. Und von daher ist dein Problem nicht nur jetzt ein Usability-Problem, sondern tatsächlich auch ein Accessibility-Problem, wo wir später noch dazukommen wollten.
Aber wenn ihr so ein neues Warenwirtschaftssystem in Betrieb nehmt, gibt es da nicht ein Pflichtenheft, das der Lieferant einzuhalten hat? Also hättest du da nicht schon reinschreiben lassen müssen, komplett bedienbar über Tastaturkürze?
Ja, also sagen wir mal so, ich bin jetzt da nicht mit in dieses Projekt involviert, aber ich hab's nur so am Rande bemerkt, dass es nicht mehr so einfach alles über Tastatur zu bedienen ist.
Ja, du hast dasselbe Problem wie wir hier. Die Leute, die das Hörfunksstudio bedienen, sind nie gefragt worden, wie es idealerweise gebaut werden sollte.
Gut, was mir auch noch aufgefallen ist, da ist ja jemand da, der sich da mit dem Gimp, glaube ich, auseinandersetzt.
Oder?
Ja, natürlich, ich bin hier. Hast du noch eine Anregung für uns?
Nee, eine gute Anregung vielleicht auch. Was mich halt stört, ist dieses Gimp, wenn ich das aufmache, egal ob ich das jetzt unter Windows oder unter Unix oder Linux aufmache, ihr habt es in so viele kleine Fenster aufgeteilt, könntet ihr das nicht einfach irgendwie in so einen Container reinmachen, dass man die komplette Anwendung an sich komplett...
Ich weiß schon, was du meinst, du bist nicht der Erste, der uns darauf hinweist. Na ja, es gibt halt so verschiedene Konzepte, ob man eine Anwendung unbedingt immer ein Fenster hat, auch wenn man mehrere Dokumente in ihr bedient, oder ob man vielleicht auch besser mit anderen Anwendungen interagieren will und mit seinem Desktop und deshalb vielleicht nicht immer gleich den ganzen Bildschirm zu platschen.
Hatten wir die Diskussion nicht gerade gestern?
Wenn du dir Photoshop zum Beispiel mal anguckst, die machen das also auf dem Mac eigentlich auch genau so, wie Gimt es unter Windows und Mac macht, nämlich für jedes Bild ein eigenes Fenster aufmachen und dann hat man vielleicht noch so zwei Paletten, die in irgendeiner Weise zu dem Bild gehören und da sind die ständigen Kontrollelemente drin. Und wenn ich zwei, drei Bilder aufhabe, dann hab ich eben zwei, drei Fenster plus meine Paletten.
Was mir noch aufgefallen ist, ist nicht immer speziell bei Gimt, aber es vermehrt es bei neuerem Programm. Wenn jetzt zum Beispiel ein Fehler, also ich hab was eingegeben zum Beispiel, irgendwo in dem Feld. So jetzt geb ich diesen Datensatz einfach frei. Meinetwegen über die Maus oder über die Tastatur. Jetzt kommt irgendeine Fehlermeldung. Jetzt zeigt er mir die an. Ist okay. Diese kann ich wieder bestätigen mit der Maus oder mit der Tastatur. Macht natürlich mit der Tastatur, wenn es schneller geht. So, jetzt hätt ich gerne wieder, dass die Leute darauf achten, dass dann der Fokus wieder da ist, wo ich vorher war. Dass ich nicht extra nochmal mit der Maus dann in dieses Fenster reinklicken muss.
Dein Arbeitsablauf soll möglichst nicht unterbrochen werden. Du siehst den Dialog und musst nicht zur Maus greifen, sondern drückst Esc oder OK und er geht weg und du machst einfach weiter. So soll das idealerweise schon sein. Das ist nicht immer alles ganz so einfach, aber es wird schon auch sehr viel Wert darauf gelegt inzwischen.
Danke Michael.
Okay.
Hey Tim, äh, ja, wo waren wir eigentlich stehen geblieben?
Wir waren bei den User Interfaces stehen geblieben. Man hat eben an diesem Anrufer auch ganz schön gesehen. Erstens, jeder hat da so seine eigene Welt und das, was für den einen funktioniert, funktioniert für den anderen nicht. Ich denke mal, Ellen wird da ein Lied von singen können. Oder?
Ja, das ist nicht so einfach. Man, also es gibt auch nicht die Gebrauchstauglichkeit oder Usability als solches, sondern immer nur bezogen auf bestimmte Nutzer in einem bestimmten Kontext für eine bestimmte Aufgabe. Das heißt, es ist sehr, sehr, sehr schwierig, eine Anwendung sowohl für den dümmsten anzunehmenden User, also für den berühmten DAO, zugänglich zu machen als auch für Power-User. Gerade im GIMP ist das sicher ein großes Problem. Da gibt es immer eine Diskussion darüber.
Ein weiteres Problem ist auch natürlich, dass wir versuchen, das für mehrere Plattformen zu programmieren. Und was auf Mac und Linux vielleicht noch ganz gut funktioniert, funktioniert unter Windows gar nicht. Und das ist Fenstermanagement. Das ist tatsächlich kaum benutzbar, wenn man eine Anwendung hat, die mehrere Fenster hat unter Windows. Weil das einfach ein Konzept ist, was auf dieser Plattform bisher wenig benutzt wird. Obwohl inzwischen der Trend da ist, dass auch unter Windows das vermehrt Abschied genommen wird von dem Windows in Windows-Metaphram.
Also ich finde es furchtbar.
Der Multiple Document Interface heißt das, was die früher z.B. in Word hatten. Also ein Mutterfenster, in dem alle deine Dokumente drin sind. Dadurch kannst du eben nicht mehr mit anderen Anwendungen interagieren. Wenn du es im Vollbildmodus hast, dann kannst du gar nicht mehr woanders was rauskopieren und da wieder einfügen, ohne eben das Fenster zu minimieren. Und das ist der Ansatz, den der Anrufer sich, glaube ich, gerade gewünscht hatte für den GIMP eigentlich. Hat aber eben auch Nachteile, weil du eben nicht mehr so schnell mit anderen Programmen in Austausch kommst.
Der größte Nachteil ist eigentlich tatsächlich, dass ich dieses Konzept von Fenstern und wie bewege ich Fenster, mit welchen Keyboard Shortcuts kann ich vielleicht auch das Fenster vergrößern oder minimieren, dass ich das nochmal in der Anwendung implementiere und da sieht es leicht anders aus. Es hat nicht die gleichen Fensterrahmen und die Dinger funktionieren nicht genauso wie die großen Fenster. Das heißt, es gibt so Fenster und da drin gibt es nochmal Fenster und die funktionieren wieder ganz anders.
Also dass jeder so seine ganz anderen Anforderungen hat, das ist mir auch letzte Woche wieder ganz klar geworden. Da war ich in Karlsruhe auf dem Bedienungstag. Der Helm war auch da und da gab es das ein oder andere zu sehen. Ganz aufschlussreich fand ich die Accessibility-Ecke. Das war eigentlich wirklich sehr nett zusammengestellt. Technologien und Leute vor allem, die sich da auch konkret mit beschäftigen, um eben die, was war noch gleich das tolle deutsche Wort, was du da vorhin für?
Barrierefreiheit oder Zugänglichkeit.
Genau, die Zugänglichkeit zum Computer ermöglichen sollen. Da gibt es natürlich eine Menge. Ein großer populärer Bereich ist natürlich die Technologie für Blinde. Ich hab mir das dann auch mal live demonstrieren lassen. Das war alles ganz aufregend. Da gab es so einen jungen Blinden-Könnel-Hacker, der so unter Linux-Treiber programmiert hat für Breyer Terminals. Sehr nett aus Frankreich. Der hat mir das mal gezeigt und haben auch ein bisschen mal unseren Typing-Speed miteinander verglichen. Und er hatte so ein spezielles Breyer Terminal, was mittlerweile so nicht mehr hergestellt wird. Das solltet ihr vielleicht mal kurz mal erläutern. Also Breyer sollte euch ja bekannt sein. Das ist quasi so ein Digital-Code. 6-Bits werden halt, also es sind so kleine Stifte, die eben so aus dem Gerät hochschießen, sodass man die eben fühlen kann.
Das heißt, ein Breyer-Zeichen hat 6-Bits?
Genau, das normale Breyer-Zeichen hat 6-Bits. Das sind also 3 mal 2. Da kann man halt so A bis Z und Zahlen, was noch alles genau drin ist, mit abbilden. Für die Computer-Benutzung gibt es allerdings noch zwei zusätzliche darunter. Der eine links unten wird verwendet, um zwischen Groß- und Kleinbuchstaben zu unterscheiden, was Breyer so erstmal nicht hergibt. Das brauchen wir ja nicht unbedingt zu sehr. Und der andere wird verwendet, um den Cursor zu markieren. Das heißt, wenn unten beide an sind, da ist da der Cursor. Den Cursor dann natürlich wieder ausschalten, um zu sehen, ob das Zeichen unter dem Cursor auch Groß- oder Kleinbuchstaben ist. Aber es ist erstaunlich zu sehen, mit welcher Geschwindigkeit Blinde eben damit arbeiten können. Also ein Gerät, das wir einfach rüber fassen und wir haben überhaupt keine Schäckung, was überhaupt ist. Das ist eine Frage der Sensibilisierung sicherlich.
Man hat dann so eine Brei-Zeile, wo man mit dem Finger drüber zieht und quasi eine Zeile Text.
Also sind sie halt extrem textorientiert. Mit GUIs können Sie als Herz wie wenig anfangen, das ist verständlich. Und navigieren im Prinzip immer auf einer Zeile, genau genommen sogar auf einer halben Zeile. Also wenn man so einen normalen Textbildschirm hat, der hat ja so 80 Zeichen pro Zeile und diese normale Brei-Terminal hat in der Regel 40. Das heißt, sie schalten auch noch mal zwischen linke Hälfte, rechte Hälfte rum und eben auch noch hoch und runter stimmen sie eben die Zeile auf den Bildschirmen, die sie gerade lesen. Man kann dann natürlich auch damit schreiben, das heißt, es gibt dann auch so ein 8-Tasten-Interface, sodass man mit 8 Fingern gleichzeitig diese Bit-Kombinationen eingibt. Also wo wir halt auf eine Taste drücken, drücken wir sozusagen auf 8 gleichzeitig und haben damit dann eben das entsprechende Zeichen, also auch mit groß Kleinschreibung, weiß nicht ganz genau, wofür die 8 immer verwendet wird.
Hört uns vielleicht gerade ein Blinder zu, der das erklären kann.
Er hat's mir erklärt, aber ich hab's natürlich wieder nicht...
03317097110, jemand, der eine Breit-Tastatur verwendet, wäre jetzt ganz hilfreich.
Genau, das fänden wir super, wenn da mal jemanden noch mal ein bisschen von den Betroffenen her bezeichnen könnte.
Und der war damit schneller als du auf der Querztastatur?
Er war nicht langsamer, sagen wir's mal so. Also ich glaube, wir hatten etwa den gleichen Typing-Speed und das war schon ziemlich bemerkenswert noch und etwa die gleiche Fehlerrate. War so mein Eindruck, keine große Statistik darüber geführt, aber das war schon alles ganz bemerkenswert. Es gab da noch ein paar andere lustige Geräte zum Bilderlesen, das hast du auch noch ausprobiert, aber das war noch nicht so ganz der Hit, oder?
Ja, das habe ich ausprobiert. Das war ein Gerät, wo man mit einer Maus, an der oben auch noch mal viermal 6-Bit-Bright-Randen gefügt waren, über eine Fläche gefahren ist. Man muss natürlich die Augen zumachen. Und auf der Fläche wurde irgendwie so ein Bild wiedergespiegelt und die Grautöne oder Dunkeltöne, immer wenn es irgendwie dunkel war im Bild, dann haben sich eben diese Punkte eingedrückt und wenn es hell war, dann haben die sich hochgedrückt. Und so musste man eben über die Fläche fahren und dann raten, was dieses Bild ausmacht.
Das Bild erfühlen, ja?
Genau, erfühlen. Es war unheimlich schwierig, weil man immer nur einen ganz kleinen Ausschnitt aus dem Bild hat. Und wenn man aus dem Bild rausfällt, hat die Maus angefangen zu vibrieren. Ich habe den Unterschied zwischen Vibrieren und normalen Bewegungen nicht so ganz spüren können, also ich glaube, dass ich im Blinden einfach ein bisschen sensibler bin. Aber auch die Blinden haben gesagt, dass es unheimlich schwierig ist, weil man eben immer das Gesamtbild im Kopf aufbauen muss und eigentlich nur einen kleinen Ausschnitt auf einmal fühlt. War aber auf jeden Fall sehr interessant.
Ja, es ist auf jeden Fall ein bemerkenswerter Sport, rauszubekommen, wie man den Computer noch verwendbarer machen kann, unabhängig davon, ob das jetzt von irgendeiner Behinderung ausgeht oder nicht. Erwähnenswert finde ich auch noch so Grafiktabletts als Technologie, wo man eben auch so direkt mit dem Stift drauf schreibt oder teilweise auch direkt auf den Bildschirm. Bei den PDAs hat man das. Auch so alternative Eingabemethoden.
Da habe ich neulich ein sehr schönes Ding im Netz gefunden. Und zwar gibt es da einen Prototypen, bisher wohl nur das Kamerad, kann man also noch nicht kaufen. Aber es gab dann ein ganz interessantes Demo-Video. Und zwar ist es ein Grafiktablett erst mal, was auch Force-Feedback, nennt man das glaube ich, in so Spielen irgendwie hat. Das heißt, es kann irgendwie vibrieren und einem halt über das Tablett mitteilen, dass man gerade mit dem Finger über einem Button oder einem anderen User-Interface-Element ist. Und der Clou ist eigentlich, dass oben eine Kamera sitzt, die die Hände filmt. Und man arbeitet jetzt mit beiden Händen auf diesem Tisch und sieht seine Hände auf dem Computer-Monitor als Schatten.
Lass uns mal kurz die Ull durchsagen, dann könnt ihr euch das nämlich alle gleich mal anklicken. www.taktiva.com Das Gerät heißt Taktapad und gibt es noch nicht. Es ist ein Konzept, aber die haben sehr schöne Demovideos, wo sie das auch schon zeigen, wie sie das integrieren wollen.
Das Tolle ist eigentlich, dass man viel direkter mit dem Computer interagiert, weil man sozusagen seine Finger so auf dem Bildschirm hat. Nur kann man durch die Finger durchgucken, das heißt, man sieht auch, wo man eigentlich gerade mit den Finger drübersitzt. Und man hat eben nicht nur einen Mauszeiger, den man jetzt vielleicht mit seinem Zeigefinger durch die Gegend schiebt, sondern man hat ja zehn Finger. Das heißt, ich kann mit der rechten Hand irgendein Objekt festhalten und mit der linken Hand meine Arbeitsfläche drunter wegscrollen. Oder ich kann dieses Objekt nehmen mit zwei Fingern und kann es eben um 30 Grad drehen und muss dafür nicht extra noch irgendwelche speziellen Key-Shortcuts drücken, sondern es ist ein sehr direktes Interagieren.
Ich brauche ein vergleichsweise großes Display. Oder verkleinert es meine Hände auch so, dass ich, weiß ich nicht, kleine Elemente ein...
Das ist ein Konzept. Ich denke mal, das würde man schon machen.
Wie stellen die sich das vor mit der Tastatur? Blendet das dann irgendwie auf Fingerschnipp eine halbe Tastatur ein? Oder wie wird das...
Das ist ja gar nicht dazu gedacht, die Tastatur zu ersetzen, sondern eigentlich eher die Maus. Weil man hat ja im Prinzip zwei Mäuse.
Ja, aber wenn ich doch ohnehin schon da bin.
Dein Einbart ist natürlich gerechtfertigt. Du bist ziemlich weg vom Keyboard damit. Du hast tatsächlich deine Hände nicht mehr auf dem Keyboard, du hast deine Hände auf zehn Mäusen.
Also aus meiner Sicht, als kleiner User eben.
Man könnte dann einfach eine Geste einbauen, zum Beispiel. Dann kommt halt einfach so ein Onscreen-Keyboard und dann kann man dann eben auch direkt auf dem Bildschirm quasi die Tastatur bedienen. Also das stelle ich mir jetzt nicht so schwierig vor.
Sicher nicht.
Das müsste super gehen eigentlich. Also das ist echt ein spitzen Demomovie. Guckt euch das mal an. Das ist echt bemerkenswert. Ich hoffe, dass das irgendeiner baut. Das sieht echt schick aus. Man kann da so reinzoomen, indem man auf das Ding draufdrückt. Dann geht so der Bildschirm nach hinten und...
Wenn man die Hände zu sich zieht, da ist eine Kamera oben drüber, dann erkennt die Kamera das und zoomt raus.
Also das ist traumhaft. Echt super. Auf jeden Fall vielversprechender als so ein anderer Klassiker. Der Datenhandschuh. Wir erinnern uns... Lorne Mowerman, der Rasenmäher-Mann. Damals, so wie Cyberspace, Isn't it wonderful, kein Staub und... Ich fand ihn nicht so spannend im Film, aber er hat auf jeden Fall einen riesen Tamm-Tamm erzeugt. Es war halt dieser... Er war nicht komplett ein 3D, sondern nur diese Einzelsequenzen, diese 3D, wo sie dann alle so ganz total cybermäßig und dann mit dem Datenhandschuh. Also Datenhandschuhe ist Cyberclough, für die Leute, die das nicht kennen. Es war so die Idee, dass man seine Hand als Eingabegerät benutzt. Das heißt, man zieht sich so ein Handschuh an, in dem waren dann solche... Was waren das? Glasfaser, Stränge... Also auf jeden Fall konnte man quasi durch die Biegung der Finger dadurch erfassen. Man hat halt seinen Finger bewegt und die Beugung war halt messbar. Dann hat man versucht, das Ganze in Realtime auf 3D-Computers zu machen. Meistens so Silicon-Graphics-Maschinen, die nur halbwegs in der Lage waren, schnell in Realtime 3D dran zu basteln. Also alles auch scheiße teuer. Und dann dachten sie halt, das wäre jetzt mal ein tolles Interface. Ich glaube, das war eher ein bisschen Wunschdenken. Das sah mal so albern aus.
Ich habe gerade das... The Plague, wie er da steht und der FBI-Beamte im Besuch kommt. Hat der nicht auch einen Datenanschuh an oder hat der nur diesen dämlichen Cyberhelm auf?
Meistens gibt es dazu, denn tatsächlich immer noch diesen dämlichen Helm und das macht es ganz natürlich noch viel albern. Unfassbar.
Ja, da nennt man sich eben The Plague.
Also ist alles gestorben. Naja, aber wir waren ja so ein bisschen auf dem Weg zu den modernen User Interfaces. Da gehört das auf jeden Fall nicht dazu. Die GUI. Oh ja, die GUI, die GUI, die GUI. Also irgendwann kam das mal auf. Dieser... Jetzt bin ich gerade ein bisschen verwirrt. Hat der Dirk Engelbart das eigentlich in seinem Fenster-Konzept da auch schon drin gehabt?
Ähm, ich glaube nicht. Ich glaube, der hatte noch kein Fenster-Konzept. Das war jetzt noch...
Ja, der nächste Schritt war dann... Also es gab ja dann... Es gibt so ein paar sagenumwobene Ideenquellen in dieser ganzen Computerszene. Und was auch immer wieder zum Spielen kommt, ist Xerox PARC. Also die Firma Xerox, die man heutzutage eigentlich eher so als Kopiererfirma wahrnimmt, war eine ganze Weile lang einfach das Forschungsinstitut. Und PARC, Palo Alto Research Center, ist schon fast mythisch. Dort wurden also alle Produkte erfunden, die in den nächsten 30 Jahren populär waren. Nur hat Xerox mit fast keinem einzigen jemals irgendein Geld damit verdient. Ich weiß nicht, was sie da falsch gemacht haben, wahrscheinlich alles. Aber offensichtlich waren die Forschungsbedingungen da ganz toll. Also sie hatten da extrem begabte Leute und die haben da so Sachen erfunden wie Ethernet, Mäuse, Fenster, grafische Benutzeroberflächen, you name it. Also die Liste ist sehr lang. Und dort hat sich auch Steve Jobs dann eben mal die Sache mit der Maus in den Fenstern abgeguckt und das im Prinzip in Apples erst einmal einen wirklichen kommerziellen Massencomputer eingebaut.
Was da vor 30 Jahren erfunden wurde, ist im Grunde auch das Letzte, oder? Also ich meine, seitdem steht es. Ja, ist da wesentlich was dazugekommen?
Es ist glaube ich überhaupt erst mal das Refinement angesagt. Also die Grundidee hat wohl gestimmt, zumindest war es ausreichend populär. Keine Ahnung, wie ihr es so seht, ihr seid ja noch sehr viel näher am Fenster. Also GUI, also diese Idee, Fenster, User Interface, Maus, also dieses typische Grundgeräusch.
Was ist eigentlich immer noch da? Also im Prinzip hat sich da nicht so viel geändert, aber vielleicht hat sich dann in der Art und Weise, wie wir die User Interfaces in die Fenster reinbauen, schon was getan seitdem, ich hoffe doch.
Man versucht halt, das auszubauen, jetzt in 3D wie Looking Glass von Sun, wo man eigentlich den Fenster nur noch eine Rückseite gibt und da irgendwelche Notizen dran macht. Also so grundsätzlich, grundlegend anders ist das auch nicht. Aber eine Weiterentwicklung, die eben in eine bestimmte Richtung gehen soll. Später mal wahrscheinlich in den richtigen 3D-Desktop, wo man eben Objekte hat, die man durch die Gegend schiebt.
Da glaub ich ja noch nicht dran.
Da glaub ich auch noch nicht so ganz dran.
Also 3D hat echt einen schlechten Stand. Wo ich auch immer irgendwie Leute habe fabulieren sehen, man müsste ja jetzt mal 3D-Interfaces machen, kam eigentlich niemals eine zweite Antwort. Also da sind so viele Sachen ungelöst. Eigentlich ist 2D noch nicht so richtig. Also kleine Schritte sind dann immer schon so große Sachen. Also dass ich jetzt hier auf meinem Macintosh zum Beispiel mit zwei Fingern auf mein Trackpad gehe und dann scrolle ich, das ist für mich schon so ein Produktivitätsgewinn. Da möchte ich gar nicht über irgendwelchen 3D-Kram nachdenken.
Ich denke, man kann mit 3D schon ein paar ganz interessante Sachen machen auf dem Desktop, die auch nicht nur schick aussehen. Klar ist es irgendwie toll, wenn das Fenster so in Wellen schlägt, bevor es irgendwie unten im Dock reinkracht, aber davon hat keiner wirklich was. Doch, es gibt halt schon so ein paar Sachen, die einem... Also was mich selber eingrückt hat zum Beispiel ist dieses Feature von Mac OS X, wenn man den User umschaltet. Man kann also irgendwie im laufenden System sagen, lass mich mal an deinen Rechner ran, ich hab ja auch einen Account. Und dann switcht man eben den User um und was dann passiert ist, der ganze Desktop fährt so ein bisschen weg. Man erkennt, dass er eigentlich eine Oberfläche von einem Kubus ist und dreht so nach links weg und mein Desktop kommt nach vorne. Da kann ich mich dann einloggen und die Metapher kommt total gut rüber, weil ich weiß irgendwie, okay, mein ganzer Desktop, der ist jetzt noch da auf der anderen Seite von diesem Würfel und ich kann ihn jederzeit wieder zurückdrehen, den Würfel und alles ist so, wie es vorher mal war. Das ist 3D, was funktioniert. Da verschwinden nicht einfach die Sachen und ich weiß nicht, wo sie hin sind, sondern...
Ja, das ist so die Augmented Reality so ein bisschen, ne, auf dem Computer. Also, dass man so das, was da passiert, einfach besser visualisiert bekommt. Aber ich denke bei 3D-Interfaces, es gab bei IREX, also den SGI Unix-Varianten, gab es schon relativ früh so auch so 3D-Desktop-Spielreihen. Also neben dem Standard User Interface, was sie ausgeliefert haben, was auch nur normal Fenster war, hatten sie halt immer wieder so diesen so dieser klassische Mythos, so ich fliege in 3D über mein Dateisys, so 3D-Filemanager, kennt man aus Jurassic Park. Das war wahrscheinlich sogar genau das Ding. Oder irgendeine Inkarnation davon. Und ich fand es furchtbar. Also es hat mir einfach keinerlei Überblick gemacht. Apple hatte auch mal irgendwie so eine komische Phase, wo sie in ihrem Research-Institut so ein Klembim produziert haben. Es ist einfach alles komplett sinnfrei.
Ja, Apple hat aber ganz nette Visualisierung. Also Sven hat ja gerade schon gesagt, wenn man beim Login, wenn sich der Kubus praktisch umdreht und man sieht man es einfach auf der anderen Seite vom Rechner oder vom Interface, wie auch immer. Und sie haben auch in ihren Office-Programmen ganz schöne Features drin, wo man eben, wenn man zum Beispiel in Open Office den Stylisten aufruft, das ist so ein kleines Tool-Fenster, das dann aufgeht, das aus dem Menü aufruft, dann geht im Toolbar, aus dem Button, das Fenster in so einer kleinen dynamischen Form auf. Und naja, man sieht eben praktisch, wo es herkam. Und wenn man es wieder schließt, dann verschwindet es auch wieder in den Button rein.
Das ist wie so eine Sprechblase?
Na ja, das Fenster selbst knautscht sich so zusammen und auseinander. Und man sieht eben, wo es herkommt und weiß ganz genau, wo man es wiederfindet, wenn man es aus Versehen geschlossen hat oder so. Und wenn man es eben immer umständlich aus dem Menü aufgerufen hat, weiß man auch, wo der Toolbar-Button dafür ist.
Ich bin Walder, dann 101, 5.
Eine nach halb null, äh, Spritz Info. Eine nach halb null, ja eine nach halb zwölf. Heute Nacht wird es richtig wolkig. Stellenweise kann es sogar ein bisschen Regen geben bei Temperaturen zwischen 10 und 15 Grad. Morgen wird es dann wolkiger als heute. Es soll aber bis zum Abend trocken bleiben. Die Höchsttemperaturen liegen zwischen 21 und 26 Grad und die Meldungen, die liegen bei Gerald Kötter-Henrich.
Die beiden in Afghanistan getöteten Bundeswehrsoldaten sind nach Deutschland überführt worden. Eine Luftwaffenmaschine mit den Särgen an Bord landet am Abend auf dem militärischen Teil des Kölner Flughafens. Die Soldaten waren vor vier Tagen im Nordosten Afghanistans getötet worden, als beim Verladen von Munition drei Lastwagen explodierten. Das Verfahren um die Vertrauensfrage im Bundestag stößt auch bei SPD-Politikern auf starke Bedenken. Die Bundestagsabgeordnete Hoffmann will deshalb das Bundesverfassungsgericht in Karlsruhe anrufen. Sie habe Zweifel, ob die unechte Vertrauensfrage von Bundeskanzler Schröder mit dem Grundgesetz übereinstimme. Schröder selbst will sich am Freitag bei der Vertrauensfrage der Stimme enthalten. Das Arbeitslosengeld II in Ostdeutschland soll auf Westniveau angehoben werden. Der Hartz-IV-Ombudsrat schlug in seinem Zwischenbericht vor, künftig einheitlich 345 Euro zu zahlen. Wirtschaftsminister Clement will die Empfehlung umsetzen. Die Weltgesundheitsorganisation sieht wichtige Ziele ihres Kampfes gegen die Immunschwächerkrankheit AIDS gefährdet. Bis zum Jahresende sollten 3 Millionen Menschen in armen Ländern Zugang zu AIDS-Medikamenten erhalten. Dies sei nicht mehr zu schaffen, weil es an Geldfehle teilte die WHO in Genf mit. Nach ihren Berechnungen sind mindestens weitere 18 Milliarden US-Dollar nötig, um den Kampf gegen AIDS in den nächsten drei Jahren erfolgreich zu führen. Fußball-Weltmeister Brasilien hat den Confederation Cup gewonnen. Die Brasilianer besiegten im Endspiel Argentinien mit 4 zu 1. Zuvor hatte die deutsche Mannschaft in Leipzig den dritten Platz erreicht. Die Nationalelf gewann gegen Mexiko mit 4 zu 3. Nach Verlängerung das entscheidende Tor schoss Michael Ballack. Der Verkehr auf Fritz mit zwei Meldungen. A12 Berlin Richtung Frankfurt. Oder Stau gibt es zwischen Frankfurt Süd und dem Grenzübergang Frankfurt. Da hat es einen Unfall gegeben. Der Verkehr wird an der Abfahrt Frankfurt West abgeleitet. Und Stadtverkehr Berlin Tiergarten. Wegen des Live-Aid-Konzerts am Samstag gibt es schon heute die ersten Sperrungen. Betroffen ist die Straße des 17. Juni zwischen Entlastungsstraße und Großem Stern. Ansonsten keine aktuellen Meldungen. Gute Fahrt.
3 Minuten nach halb 12.
Hallöle, Hallöle, Hallöle.
Mensch, die Stimme kenn ich doch.
Ist da ja nicht Dienstag Nacht.
Was hat die hier zu suchen? Ja, schrecken alle auf. Wissen, in so einem Zusammenhang macht Kutnalo wieder Werbung.
Entweder für sich oder für Margarine.
In diesem Fall für sich. Ich finde aber Werbung machen eigentlich ziemlich blöde. Wir sind ja hier alle keine Crema-Seelen. Von daher die nüchterne, sachliche Ansage.
Best of Video-Schnips der Saison.
Mit anschließender Party an den Platten-Teller.
Legendary Patrick Katani.
Und denn ist erst mal lange Zeit ja nichts. So, das war es jetzt. Das war keine Werbung. Sondern war echt einfach nur eine nüchterne Information. Wie man sich manchmal eben Wasserstandsmeldungen wünscht. Oder vergleichbare, ernsthafte Mitteilungen im Radio.
Die ja viel zu selten sind heutzutage.
Freitag Abend 21 Uhr in der Volksbühne Berlin am Rosa-Luxemburg-Platz und im Radio Fritz.
Fritz ist an. Chaosradio 103 hört ihr. Ellen spielt gerade an ihrem Mikrofon rum.
Ja, der Nachrichtensprecher ist größer als ich.
Länger, länger, länger. Sven ist da, Tim die Knöpfe drückt Holger und 0331 77 97 110 angerufen hat. Sabine aus Berlin. Hallo Sabine. Du hattest eine Frage.
Ja, hört ihr mich jetzt ja, ne? Ich bin seit zwei Jahren behindert und hab bisher immer Schreibarbeiten, also Büroarbeiten gemacht.
Inwiefern behindert?
Am rechten Arm. Das heißt, ich kann nicht mehr bewegen, die Hand nicht und wollte fragen, ob es dadurch also etwas Praktisches oder anderes gibt, womit ich meine linke Hand benutzen kann oder mit der linken Hand lernen kann. Also durch meine Situation war ich halt so verärgert, dass ich alle meine Geräte weggegeben habe, wo jetzt bin ich Gott sei Dank soweit wieder zu sagen, naja gut, also vielleicht gibt es da irgendwas, was ich da noch machen kann.
Mit Geräten meinst du Computer?
Ja. Oder Tastatur, ob es da, also das Zehn-Finger-System, was ich ja immer ganz gut konnte, das ist natürlich jetzt vorbei.
Ja, spätestens bei einem großen P, also da kommst du mit der Hand, so eine Spannbreite hat die Hand ja gar nicht mehr.
Und dann mit, also Großbuchstaben, ne, so, ich kann nur die eine Hand benutzen, so.
Ich kenn das Problem, ich hatte gerade einen Unfall hinter mir, da hat mir mein Handgelenk gebrochen, hatte aber jetzt im Prinzip auch zwei Monate keine rechte Hand. Und naja, so mit meiner Computersüchtigkeit, ich meine, ich hab einen Macintosh, ein Macintosh hat serienmäßig so eine Einhandtastenunterstützung.
Die schaltet man. Eine Einhandunterstützung gibt es?
Genau. Das ist Teil des Betriebssystems seit Mensch und Gedenken und das funktioniert ziemlich super und funktioniert so, dass man im Prinzip diese ganzen Umschalttasten, also Shift, Alt und Control und alles, was es da gibt, hintereinander drücken kann. Das heißt, ich drücke auf Shift und dann merkt das ich, ah, jetzt hab ich Shift gedrückt und die nächste Taste, die ich drücke, ist dann halt so, als hätte ich Shift A gedrückt. Und das hat ziemlich gut funktioniert für mich, muss ich sagen. Natürlich war ich am Anfang auch gehandicapt, weil ich bin Rechtshändler. Ich bin natürlich nicht so fix, aber mit der Zeit ändert sich das natürlich. Man merkt so richtig, wie die Intelligenz von rechts nach links fließt und das, glaube ich, löst sich von alleine. Ich würde nicht sagen, dass es optimal war, aber die Leute, die mit mir gechattet haben, waren schon ganz schön beeindruckt.
Es fällt mir interessanterweise exakt jetzt zum ersten Mal auf, dass du deine rechte Hand ja überhaupt nicht benutzen konntest. Ich hab das nicht gemerkt, ja.
Ja, wir haben ja die ganze Zeit miteinander.
Ja, eben. Ich hab's wirklich nicht, es ist ja erstaunlich. Und ansonsten...
Ja, also ich hab keine Chance, dass es mal besser wird und deswegen aber, wie gesagt, ich bin jetzt so weit, dass ich endlich sage, so jetzt höre ich erst mal rum. Also ich mein, es wird ja viele geben, die links schreiben oder...
Also ich sag mal Spracheingabe, Spracheingabe jetzt auf so einer User-Seite, ne, funktioniert nicht?
Textverarbeitung?
Also die Bandbreite, die du mit Tastatureingaben erzielen kannst, wie willst du die in den Computer reintreten?
Ich meine, wenn es jetzt tatsächlich ums Texte schreiben geht, das meine ich.
Es gibt natürlich Diktier-Software und wenn man wirklich viel schreibt, dann mag das wirklich sinnvoll sein. Also wenn es jetzt wirklich darum geht... Aber für das Benutzen von Programmen ist Spracheingabe eigentlich allweilig.
Nee, mir ging es um Diktier...
Ja, also beende Programmen, da kommt man sich ja wirklich vor wie so ein Roboter. Nee, das ist edelnd. Ich weiß ja nicht, was für Computer, also wenn du deinen Computer jetzt eine weggegeben hast, könntest du ja einen Macintosh kaufen.
Nee, nicht mal einen Macintosh kaufen, selbst Open-Source-Software hat diese Features alle schon. Blick los. Also, ich hab gerade noch mal geguckt, weil ich hab das natürlich auch noch nie benutzt. Ich hatte noch nicht das Glück, mir die Hand zu brechen bisher. Aber auf meinem Gnome-Desktop zum Beispiel kann ich also auch Keyboard-Accessibility-Features einschalten und da gibt es auch solche Sticky Keys, das heißt, dass ich nicht mehr gleichzeitig drücken muss, tatsächlich die Modifier, also irgendwie Shift und den Buchstaben, sondern ich kann es nacheinander machen. Und ich denke wahrscheinlich dürftest du da auf jeden Plattformen inzwischen was finden. Unter anderem auch weil es inzwischen ja in vielen Ländern auch Gesetz ist, dass zumindest in den nächsten Jahren irgendwann Software, die irgendwo eingesetzt wird, in Behörden und so weiter, eben solche Features haben muss.
Ja, ja, das habe ich auch gehört, dass das mal kommen soll, aber die Deutschen sind ja mit so was sehr spät.
Oh, das ist 2006 soll das da sein, das heißt, wer hier Software noch nicht angefangen hat, das einzubauen, die ist dann nächstes Jahr vom Markt.
Aha, ja gut, ich danke euch. Das hört sich gut an.
Ich gucke gerade mal hier in Windows, ob man da eine Tastatur was machen kann oder nicht.
Ich kann das nochmal zusammen, das hat für mich wirklich extrem gut funktioniert und zwar so gut, dass ich das teilweise auch heute noch anschalte, gerade wenn man so ein bisschen im Lazy-Modus ist und einfach, keine Ahnung, rechts einfach noch sein Eis halten möchte oder so, oder sein Getränk, wenn man halt so abends am Strand in seinem Schlafzimmer liegt, dann ist das einfach manchmal echt extrem entspannend, weil man braucht halt auch dann wirklich nur noch eine Hand und ich konnte halt nach der Weile, man tendiert dann zu so ein bisschen so seine Hand wie so ein, keine Ahnung, wie so ein Pendel über der Tastatur fliegen zu lassen. Kann ich mir gut vorstellen, das war bei mir auch ein Schock.
Tolle ist, dass du das wahrscheinlich noch nicht mal selbst einstellen musst, sondern wenn du einfach mal eine Umschalltaste zum Beispiel länger gedrückt lässt, dann kommt von selbst so ein Dialog hoch, der fragt, ob du die Sticky Keys einschalten möchtest. Ah, also zumindest unter Linux ist das bei Gnome und bei KDE so, Windows, weiß nicht.
Keine Ahnung, werden wir aber noch rausfinden, Sabine. Ich sage jetzt erstmal danke für deinen Anruf. Wir haben nämlich noch jemanden in der Leitung, der sagt, wie es bei Windows geht.
Ich danke euch allen.
Und wir begrüßen Gabriel, hallo.
Ja hallo.
Also ich benutze unter Windows manchmal die Tastatur-Maus, wenn irgendwie die Maus grad nicht will oder so was. Und da gibt es auch, das heißt Eingabe-Hilfen und diese Feststellfunktion heißt Einrastfunktion unter Windows. Findet man über die Systemsteuerung, da gibt es dann Eingabe-Hilfen, haben die meisten wahrscheinlich nur versehentlich mal drauf geklickt und dann wieder raus. Und da kann man irgendwie Einrastfunktionen aktivieren und dann passiert das halt genauso wie du sagtest mit Umschalt, Steuerung und Alt, dass die halt irgendwie so festgestellt bleiben. Und ich glaube, das kriegt man irgendwie auch über eine Tastenkombination oder Shift irgendwie 10 Sekunden gedrückt halten. Ich hab's grad mal probiert, passierte nix, aber das lässt sich ja dann rausfinden.
Na hier bei mir passiert auch nichts, aber ich weiß nicht, ob wir auch das XP benutzen, das jeder zu Hause benutzt, weil das ist ja hier Konzernartig oder so. Ich kriege hier auch gerade noch einen anderen Tipp. Ja einen hab ich noch, Andreas Todtnau.
Guten Tag, ich wollte eine andere Lösung vorschlagen, wenn man die eine Hand nicht verwendet kann. Da ist in letzter Zeit in der Schweiz extrem verbreitet geworden, diese Einhandtastaturen. Das ist so ein kleines Gerät, passt genau in die Hand, damit kann man Tastaturen und Maus ziemlich gut steuern.
Wie passt genau in die Hand? Ist das eine winzig kleine Tastatur, die ich mit spitzem Finger drücke?
Das ist so ein Knubbeln, den man in die Hand nimmt. Da gibt es verschiedene Modifier, die man drücken kann. Damit drückt man verschiedene Tastenkombinationen, aber nur mit vier Fingern und dem Daumen.
Ich kann mir das noch nicht so richtig vorstellen. Ich habe also praktisch einen Handschmeichler, an dem drücke ich so dran rum?
Ja, so wie wenn man eine Flasche in der Hand hätte, dann hätte man verschiedene Tasten. Damit kann man Tastatur-Eingaben emulieren oder mit der Maus etwas anstellen. Das ist jetzt in der Schweiz recht verbreitet, vor allem auch bei Leuten, die nur eine Hand frei haben, aus irgendwelchen Gründen, weil sie sich hier telefonieren.
Gibt es da eine Webseite dazu, dass man sich das angucken kann?
Ich habe hier gerade etwas gefunden. Und zwar heißt das Frogpad. Frogpad, also wie Frosch, F-R-O-G, pad.com. Keine Ahnung, ob es das auch in Deutschland gibt, aber das ist so ein dreimal fünf Tastenfeld mit Tasten drumherum. Die gibt es in einer Links- und Rechtshänderversion. Einfach zum USB anschließen, verhält sich wahrscheinlich für eine ganz normale Tastatur, aber hat eine ganz andere Ergonomie.
Das ist dann wahrscheinlich genau das, was Sabine sucht.
Das hätte ich auch mal gerne ausprobiert im Krankenhaus.
Vielen, vielen Dank, Andre. Und gute Nacht. Wen hatte ich da gerade unterbrochen?
Tim hatte ich unterbrochen, genau. Ja, ich kriege die ganze Zeit lustige, interessante Links zu dem Thema hier von Leuten, die sich auch schon bei die Hand gebrochen haben, hier gerade nochmal betont. Und das Problem ist bekannt. Also es gibt auf jeden Fall interessante Geräte, die ich bis jetzt eben auch noch nicht kannte, aber wieder was gelernt. So will man das doch haben. Sehr interaktive Sendung hier, muss ich sagen, sehr schön.
Chaosradio 103, User Interface ist unser Thema und Accessibility, also Barrierefreiheit möglich ist oder überhaupt Computerbedienung, Tastaturbedienung, wenn einem ein Arm fehlt, eine Hand fehlt oder zumindest die Bewegung eingeschränkt ist. Frank aus Gelto weiß noch was, wie es bei Windows funktioniert, mit der Feststelltaste, die gedrückt bleibt. Ich guck mal, eins, zwei, drei, vier, fünf.
Tatsächlich.
So klasse, ich bin immer wieder so leicht zu beeindrucken. Vielen Dank, Frank.
Diese Frogpad-Tastatur ist sogar über Bluetooth, das heißt, man hat noch nicht mal ein Kabel. Kann man das auch schön unter der Decke und so.
Fünfmal die Schifftaste drücken, das fällt, glaube ich, in den Bereich, wie heißt das? Discoverability? Na, also das ist natürlich auch so ein Aspekt von User Interfaces. Nämlich, dass man eben das nicht erklärt kriegen muss und nicht jemand zu dir sagt, du drück mal fünfmal die Schifftaste, sondern dass man quasi von alleine drauf kommt. Finchers sollten irgendwo zu finden sein.
Der Intuitiv am besten. Wobei, dann brauchst du ein riesengroßes Keyboard. Und ein Tick länger in der Leitung hängt, weil er ein bisschen anderes Thema hat als Accessibility. Glaub ich jedenfalls Andreas aus dem Prenzlauer Berg.
Schönen Abend. Ich hab einen Einwurf in Richtung User Interface, was die Geschwindigkeit angeht. Und zwar ist noch eine Frage, kennt ihr Alias Systems aus Ameland, das ist eine Firma, Software Schmiede. Die haben in den letzten 20 Jahren also eine ganze Stückliste an Patenten angemeldet und da war auch drunter von wegen zweite Maus. Wählst du mit der ersten Maus irgendeine Tastenkombination, irgendwas erstmal an und dann erscheint was und dann mit der zweiten Maus, wirklich die du physikalisch in der Hand hast, wählst du dort dann innerhalb von Optionen, die eingeblendet werden, einen spezifischen Befehl aus.
Dann schieb ich die erste Maus zur Seite und nehme die zweite oder? Nein, ich will mit zwei Händen an zwei Mäusen.
Hardware-seitig zwei Mäuse in der Hand.
Das war die Idee von denen damals. Also als Patent angemeldet haben sie. Sie haben es noch nicht umgesetzt, aber was sie umgesetzt haben in ihrer Software jeweils, die sie immer wieder, also weiter pflegen, ist trotzdem was sehr, sehr Gutes. Das funktioniert mit einer Maus, aber das ist so, dass du links unten, also mit Steuerung, Shift und Alt, dass du mehrere Kombinationen hast. Und je nachdem, welche Maus hast du, dann drückst du in unterschiedliche Kontext-Menüs, die so sind, dass du dann ganz schnell, also im Millisekundenbereich die Maus bewegen kannst und hast, also nach Übungszeit natürlich, wenn du weißt, wo ist was, anhand der eingeblendeten Icons, die mitten auf dem Bildschirm dort entstehen, wo der Mauszeiger vorher war, dass du dort total schnell ein Befehl angewählt hast und das ist...
Meinst du dieses Interface, wo das dann so im Kreis um den Mauszeiger herum ist und dann wird man das aus? War das wirklich von Alias? War das nicht ein Standardinterface von IREX?
Das kann sein. Nein, also die hatten glaube ich auch so weit... Ich weiß, früher die Software erst auf Unix und eventuell IREX hergestellt und das wurde dann erst auf Windows-Plattformen übertragen. Aber die Idee, also ich kenn's jetzt zuerst mal nur jetzt von dieser Firma...
Zu patentieren ist natürlich eine super Methode, die Verbreitung von vornherein zu einzuschränken. Haben sich wahrscheinlich selber ans Bein geschossen mit. Ich fand das auch ganz interessant, aber ich hab eigentlich noch nie eine Software gehabt, die das wirklich verwendet hat. Das lag wahrscheinlich an dem Patent.
Wozu genau werden dann die, wird die zweite Maus verwendet? Also das ist mir jetzt noch nicht so ganz klar geworden.
Also das mit der zweiten Maus hab ich auch nicht begriffen, muss ich sagen.
Warum man da zwei, also ich mein, Icons im Kreis anzuordnen, das ist ja eine gute Sache.
Ich kenn das auch nur mit Klicken, dann kommt dieser Ring drumrum. Du redest tatsächlich von einer zweiten Hardware-Maus, die man in der anderen Hand hat, oder was?
Ja, aber das gibt's nur auf der Patentebene. Das ist nicht umgesetzt, das hat keine Verbreitung, das ist nur eine Idee, die die Firma mal durchkonzeptioniert hat und sich zumindest das Konzept als Patente anmelden lassen, um sich das einfach mal zu sichern. Ich fand nur erstaunlich, dass die Liste sehr lang ist. Da sind zig Patente, total genau durchstudiert hab ich's nicht. Aber was vielleicht noch ein anderer Punkt ist, was konkret umgesetzt ist, was es gibt, ist dann halt dann auch wieder dort bei der Firma diese Methode, dass du das, was du die letzten fünf Minuten zum Beispiel gemacht hast, in einem Sondereditor öffnen kannst und diesen Rotext an Befehlen, was dort gewesen war, einfach per Track and Drop irgendwo in einer Symbolleiste kopieren kannst. Und dort entsteht ein Icon, das du dann umbauen kannst, was du dir wieder auf einer Tastatur irgendwo draufmappen kannst und hast somit sozusagen den ganzen Workflow gespeichert als ein Makro. Das ist eine Sache, die, wenn man es oft benutzt, sehr, sehr viel Zeit sparen kann. Hab ich so bei anderen...
Makro-Recording gibt es schon in einigen Anwendungen und es sollte auch wirklich verboten sein, so was zu patentieren. Denn das ist eigentlich eine Idee, da kann eigentlich auch jeder selber draufkommen. Aber es ist bestimmt durchaus hilfreich. Dein Konzept mit den zwei Mäusen kenne ich ein bisschen so ähnlich. Es gibt diese Pie-Menüs, das weiß gar nicht, ob es da für ein deutsches Wort gibt, das ist die Kuchen-Menüs. Das ist so das Konzept, dass man eben nicht die Sachen einfach in der Liste untereinander anordnet, weil man ja dann auch hinter einem sehr langen Weg hat, dass man an seinem Menüpunkt angekommen ist, sondern dass immer wenn man irgendwo hinklickt, an der Stelle die Möglichkeiten im Kreis rum angeordnet werden. Und wenn ich dann irgendwo in eine Richtung gehe, und diese Richtungen sind immer dieselben, das heißt, ich kann es sehr gut mir merken, links oben ist immer das Fallmenü und rechts unten ist immer Edit. Und wenn ich nach rechts unten gehe und dann nach oben, dann finde ich Andu da, immer an der Stelle. Ich habe Leute gesehen, die damit arbeiten. Das ist ein verbreitetes Konzept in CAD und 3D Design Programmen. Und es ist unglaublich, wie schnell man damit arbeiten kann.
Der nächste in der Reihe ist Stefan aus Mitten.
Jawoll. Hallo.
Schönen guten Abend.
Ich habe eine ganz spezielle Frage zu GIMP. Und so habe ich da die Frage, ob es möglich ist, weil ich einen ziemlich kleinen Monitor noch habe, die ganzen Symbole kleiner zu machen.
Das ist nämlich die einzige Sache.
Ja, die gibt es tatsächlich. Und zwar, wenn du in den Präferenzesdialog gehst, solltest du das da eigentlich finden. Es gibt da den Punkt Themes. Und da gibt es ein kleines Theme. Und damit werden dann die Schriftwerte etwas kleiner, die Abstände zwischen den User Interface Elementen wird ein bisschen kleiner, die Icons werden kleiner gewählt und insgesamt schrumpft das Ganze so ein bisschen zusammen, sodass man dann eigentlich auch, sagen wir mal, so auf 800 x 600 damit noch so arbeiten kann. Wunderbar.
Und dann hatte ich noch eine andere Sache anzumerken, und zwar die Multiple Document Interface-Angelegenheit ist doch ganz praktisch und die Sache, die da vorne angewandt wurde von wegen, dass man nicht so schnell zwischen den Dokumenten hin und her springen könnte, das funktioniert doch. Da kann man doch einfach Steuerung und dann Tabulatortaste drücken, dann kommt man doch zwischen den Dokumenten hin und her. Also ich fand das eigentlich eine sehr schlaue Angelegenheit. Mich nervt das eigentlich auch ziemlich, wenn da wirklich ganz viele Fenster offen sind.
Naja, das Problem ist, dass es eben keine eindeutigen Standards gibt, wie du zwischen den einzelnen Fenstern springen kannst. Und wenn du sie eben nicht in der Reihenfolge durchgehen möchtest, sondern vielleicht eine Liste haben möchtest oder so, brauchst du meistens noch einen zusätzlichen Klick in so ein Windows-Menü, also wo dann die ganzen Fenster aufgelistet werden. Und das dauert eben einfach alles ein bisschen länger. Also es ist auch nicht nur schlecht, das Multidokument-Interface, man hat das eben weiterentwickelt zum Tab-Dokument-Interface heutzutage, wo man eben eine Übersicht über alle offenen Fenster auf einmal hat, dann auch Tasten-Shortcuts hat, um zwischen den einzelnen Tabs zu wechseln.
Weil du beim Bearbeiten von Bildern eigentlich möchtest, gerne eigentlich die Bilder nebeneinander betrachten können möchtest. Und da ist so ein Tab-Interface, was sich ganz gut eignet, so für Browser. Dieben das alle, dass man in Firefox irgendwie Tab-Brausen kann. Ich glaube Internet Explorer kriegt das jetzt auch in der neuen Version endlich so. Aber für Bilder eignet sich das natürlich nicht so gut. Wenn es dich wirklich zu sehr stört, es gibt tatsächlich für Windows und Plugin, was ein Fenster um die ganzen Gimp-Fenster herum macht.
Ja, weil das Problem ist doch einfach auch, wenn ich es unter Linux so habe, dass ich dann ganz viele Fenster offen habe, dann ist doch irgendwann unten die Status-Leiste bzw.
nicht Status-Leiste, sondern da, wo die ganzen Fenster aufgelistet sind, die ist dort dann auch irgendwann voll.
Das ist eine Sache, wo man dem Window-Manager ein bisschen auf die Sprünge helfen kann und da arbeiten wir auch gerade dran. Also ich denke mit Gimp 2.4 werden wir dann so weit sein, dass es nur noch ein Fenster-Eintrag in der Status-Zeile gibt.
Gute Nacht Stefan.
Wunderbar, danke schön.
Und hallo Fabian aus Luckenwalde.
Ja hallo, ich weiß, es passt jetzt nicht ganz zum Thema, aber ich würde jetzt gerne über Desktop-Motive reden, also nicht direkt.
Nee, tut mir leid, aber das passt überhaupt nicht zum Thema. Also da bist du jetzt völlig falsch, da würde ich sagen such dir mal einen IRC-Channel, der sich genau darum kümmert und stellt deine Fragen dar. Unser Thema sind nämlich die User Interfaces, also die Benutzer-Systeme.
Das ist ja wieder so eine Sache, wo ich mich als Macintosh-Benutzer immer so wundere. Weil das mit den Fenstern, das war da schon immer so, dass man pro Dokument ein Fenster hat und so ein richtiges Problem war es nicht. Spätestens an Mac OS X, wo sie dieses hübsche Exposé eingeführt haben, wo man so mit einem Klick...
F9.
Ja, oder über Tastatur, ich weiß immer über Maus, aber jeder hat so seine anderen... So quasi alle Fenster in so einem Miniatur-Modus schiebt und er dann irgendwie alles arrangiert. Entweder nur die Fenster eines Programms oder eben alles. Das schafft echt Übersicht und auch die Standard-Tastatur-Cuts, um einfach innerhalb eines Programms durch alle Fenster durchzurotieren, macht die Sache für mich extrem benutzbar.
Aber auch genau der Punkt, auf dem Macintosh hat zwar eine Anwendung mehrere Fenster, aber wenn ich ein Fenster dieser Anwendung tatsächlich benutze, dann kommen die anderen Fenster der Anwendung mit nach oben. Das bewegt sich... Das Betriebssystem oder der Fenstermannager weiß schon, dass er hier mit zusammengehörigen Fenstern zu tun hat. Das ist ein Konzept, was unter Windows total fehlt und deshalb landet man dann natürlich mit solchen User Interfaces Konzepten da ganz schnell auf der Lase.
Chaosradio 103 und User Interfaces, also Benutzerschnittstellen sind das Thema heute Abend. Drei Gäste habe ich, ich heiße Holger Klein. Der Tim ist da, der Sven ist da und die Ellen ist da und die kennen sich aus. Womit folgen wir weiter?
Ja, wir fühlen uns verpflichtet, auch mal ein bisschen den Marktüberblick zu geben. Denn naja, die meisten Leute denken halt sowieso, es gibt ja eigentlich nur Windows und alles andere wird sich wohl schon so ähnlich verhalten. Aber es gibt natürlich sehr unterschiedliche, also nicht sehr unterschiedliche, aber eben unterschiedliche grafische Benutzeroberflächen für die verschiedenen Betriebssysteme. Die populärsten sind, das kann man wohl klar sagen, vor allem voran natürlich Windows, also nicht weil es das beste ist, das beste GUI ist, sondern weil es das meist verbreitete ist, weil Windows eben weit verbreitet ist.
Weil es sich am einfachsten kopieren lässt, ne?
Wie auch immer, da fange ich jetzt noch mal nicht gleich so religiös an. Dann gibt es den Macintosh, der natürlich, also Mac OS war natürlich das erste System, was weit verbreitet GUI überhaupt erst mal auf den Personalkomputer gebracht hat. Und in der Open Source Welt gibt es mittlerweile auch sehr brauchbare grafische Benutzeroberflächen, die teilweise auch weiter vorne sind, ganz andere Konzepte auch ausprobieren, natürlich eine ganz andere Dynamik haben in der Entwicklung, als das jetzt bei den kommerziellen Systemen ist. Vor allem unter Linux hat sich da eben sehr viel entwickelt. Und dort sind vor allem zu nennen Gnome, das mit dem G, was, ja, da kommen wir gleich nochmal mehr zu sagen. Und das andere ist KDE, das ist das mit dem K, was so eine deutsche Lastigkeit hat, auch weil das halt hier geboren wurde in Deutschland. Und Gnome kommt aus dem, ich weiß gar nicht, wer hat denn damit angefangen? Das weißt du alles viel besser.
Ja, das kann man schon sagen. Das kommt eigentlich ursprünglich mal aus Amerika. Ich glaube, die Idee mit dem Gnome war dann ein Mexikaner, Amiguel de Icaza, aber der hat auch damals schon in Amerika gearbeitet. Und das G kommt natürlich eigentlich von GNU. Und es ist irgendwie so eine Sitte, dass man den ersten Buchstaben bei unheimlich vielen Applikationen versucht auf diesem G zu halten, solange es irgendwie das GIMP Toolkit verwendet. Das ist nämlich das, was ganz Gnome benutzt, ist das GIMP Toolkit GTK, nicht wie viele glauben das Gnome Toolkit, sondern ursprünglich war das mal was, was sich zwei Amerikaner auch wieder geschrieben haben, um von Motiv wegzukommen. Motiv war so damals die Unix, das Unix User Interface, aber es war eben nicht frei. Man musste das kaufen für relativ viel Geld. Es gab das für Studenten so erschwinglich, aber im Endeffekt konnte man da halt auch nichts dran ändern. Man war so ein bisschen fest auf diesem Motiv Zeug. Und wenn man sich das heute noch mal anguckt, das sieht schon ganz schön altbacken aus. Da hat sich einiges getan seitdem.
Ja, und KDE wurde in Deutschland entwickelt, in Ludwigsburg ursprünglich, läuft auf der Basis von dem QT Toolkit. Aber genaueres dazu kann uns der Danimo erzählen. Der ist mich gerade am Telefon, hat mir über IRC gesagt.
Du meinst, höre am Drachenfeld?
Ja, ich wollte eigentlich nur mal angerufen haben, weil Tim meinte, ja, hier bin ich.
Weil du mal anrufen solltest. Na, jetzt haben wir dich. Sag doch mal kurz was zu dir, was du machst.
Also ich mache in KDE hauptsächlich die PIM-Anwendung, das ist Information Management, das ist Kontakt, im Prinzip das, was ihr als Outlook unter Windows kennt, halt für KDE, für Linux.
Also um es nochmal klar zu sagen, du bist einer der Entwickler aus der KDE-Gemeinde, die halt an einzelnen Applikationen oder Subsystemen mit programmieren. Und was ist das beste GUI, was es gibt?
Ich weiß jetzt nicht, worauf ihr da jetzt anspielt, aber ich denke mal, das ist KDE.
Naja, das ist halt so die Frage. Also ist es natürlich verständlich, dass du irgendwie jetzt erstmal mit deinem eigenen...
Ganz, ganz, ganz im Ernst. Also es ist wirklich unheimlich schwierig zu sagen, weil ich glaube den Leuten, auch wenn sie sagen, ich mag KDE jetzt nicht so oder so. Ich meine, ich kann ja schlecht sagen, ihr habt keine Ahnung oder so, was sein mag. Aber ich denke, die Leute haben einfache Erfahrungen gemacht und alles, was wir sagen können, gut, okay, erzählt uns warum und dementsprechend dann arbeiten. Aber das ist genau das, was Alan eben schon meinte. Man kann es nicht jedem Recht machen.
Dann sag doch mal, warum aus deiner Sichtweise heraus KDE gut ist.
Also KDE hat letztendlich den großen Vorteil. Einmal ist es frei, kann man jetzt zustimmen, wie man will. Da einer sagt, okay, für meine Spiele, für meine Windows-Kompatibilität gebe ich halt auch Geld aus. Aber das ist ja gar nicht mal so der Punkt, sondern ich habe einfach die Möglichkeit, also das war meine Motivation, meine Programme dafür zu schreiben. Es ist natürlich schlecht, einem normalen User zu verkaufen, hey, du kannst Programme damit schreiben. Aber für mich war eigentlich eher so die Motivation zu sagen, hm, das gefällt mir an Windows nicht mehr. Mein Einstiegspunkt war beispielsweise zu sagen, okay, ich kann meinem Netscape oder meinem Mozilla nicht sagen, tu sowas wie aus dem Internet Explorer. Deswegen habe ich das damals in den KDE-Browser implementiert, weil es für mich einfacher ging. Aber lauter so Netzigkeiten, dass ich einfach Kontrolle über die Browser habe.
Okay, aber das gilt natürlich auch für andere Open Source-Systeme, die ja letztlich aus dem gleichen Sinn sind. Aber wenn wir jetzt mal, machen wir es mal ein bisschen härter. Nennen wir doch mal so die drei entscheidendsten Top-Features von KDE, die wirklich KDE auch signifikant von anderen GUIs unterscheiden, wo es einfach besser ist.
Also einmal die hohe Rate, wie ich Sachen wiederverwenden kann. Ich sehe also den selben Bildbetrachter kann ich im Conqueror verwenden, den kann ich als normale Applikation verwenden.
Conqueror ist der Browser?
Entschuldigung, genau.
Also redest du von dem Komponentensystem, richtig?
Genau, also das Komponentensystem, das ist etwas, was der Benutzer sagt, da sehe ich doch gar nicht, aber es macht sich letztendlich auch wieder in der Usability, doch sehr gut sieht man das wieder, einfach aufgrund der Tatsache, dass man doch wieder mit dem selben Interface konfrontiert wird und nicht nur, ja, jetzt ist es im Browser, jetzt schaut das schon wieder anders aus, das Knöpfchen links statt rechts oder so und das möchte man ja schon irgendwie vermeiden. Und ja, genau, das leistet das letztendlich. Bitte, das war ein Feature, genau. Jetzt hast du mich natürlich erwischt, so viele Features, die ich da aufzählen könnte.
Also was bei mir bei KDE mal der Punkt ist, ist, dass man wirklich alles konfigurieren kann. Das ist zu einer Seite ein absoluter Vorteil, wenn man Power-User ist und sich die Mühe macht, durch die Konfig-Menüs durchzugehen und zu verstehen, was man da tut, auch auszuprobieren, weil manchmal sind die Funktionen oder die Parameter natürlich nicht selbsterklärend. Da weiß man dann eigentlich gar nicht, was passiert, wenn man das mal an- und ausschaltet. Aber für den normalen User, also für den, der vielleicht von Windows umsteigt, ist das eben auch die größte Barriere, die größte Hürde. Wenn da eben die Defaults nicht so gesetzt sind, dass er sich zurechtfindet und dann in einen überfüllten Konfig-Dialog gehen muss, hat er eben natürlich auch ein Problem.
Danke für die Vorlage. Da wollte ich nämlich auch noch grad raus. Deswegen, ich wusste jetzt nicht so ganz, ob ich das als Vorteil rausstellen kann, weil es ist eben für mich wirklich nur ein Vorteil. Und ich kenne also auch viele Leute, die sagen, das ist mir ein bisschen zu viel. Und wir saßen jetzt auch, wie auf dem Dienstag oder so, ganz kreativ zusammen und haben so ein bisschen drüber gesponnen, was kann man denn für die nächste Generation von KDE, die jetzt bald vor der Tür steht oder uns ansteht, dass wir uns darüber Gedanken machen, ja was kann man denn besser machen? Und dabei eben diese Konfiguration auf der einen Seite. Die meisten benutzen Veränderung nicht, aber man kann den Leuten nicht einfach Funktionellität wegnehmen. Das finden die Leute ganz fies. Und da halt einen sensiblen Kompromiss zu finden.
Das ist so ein Konzept, was wir bei Gnome ja so ein bisschen probiert haben jetzt. Also, die Zeit einfach simpel zu halten, es sind erst mal sind es gar nicht mehr so viele Anwendungen. Wenn ich das Applikationsmenü aufmache, dann gibt es da halt irgendwie ein Bildbetrachter oder zwei und nicht gleich ein ganzes Submenü davon. Und wenn ich da in den Präferenzensdialog gehe, dann hat er vielleicht so die fünf, sechs Sachen, die man da so einstellen will. Und dann ist irgendwo Schluss. Und klar, für den einen ist es dann...
Ja, aber das war in der Tat das, was mich bei KDE... Also ich fand bei KDE immer toll, dass du eben wirklich dir einen Knopf dahin gemacht hast und der hat sich so verhalten, exakt wie du es willst. Aber nicht, dass du mich dann trotzdem wirklich entsetzt, dass ich bei Bildbetrachtern ein Submenü mit sieben Punkten hatte und dann schon dachte, oh mein Gott, was will ich denn jetzt? Natürlich ist das eine distributionsspezifische Sache, aber ich bin Loser.
Wenn du ein Bildbetrachter installierst, dann kriegst du die natürlich auch angezeigt.
Ja, natürlich, aber das Problem ist, dass du als stinknormaler User, was ich bin, den Knopf nicht findest, an dem du das ausschalten kannst. Und ich glaube, das wäre eigentlich was. Mach einen Knopf dahin, der heißt einfach nur kopieren Windows oder verhalte dich wie ein Windows oder irgendwie sowas. Also der das einfach ausschaltet, dass du die Hürde etwas niedriger setzt. Also dass du nicht einfach zum Entsetzen beim User erzeugst, du sagst, ich werd grad erschlagen, dann benutze ich's lieber nicht.
Aber dann kriegst du genau das Problem, was du hast, wenn du Microsoft einsetzst in den neueren Versionen, also Windows letztendlich, da kriegst du Einträge, die länger nicht benutzt wurden, die werden einfach ausgeblendet. Und ich hab jetzt mehrfach die Erfahrung gemacht mit, ich sag mal, so einem wirklich durchschnittlichen Computerannutzer, wobei man mit dem Begriff durchschnittlich natürlich vorsichtig sein muss, der dann einfach gesagt hat, wo ist denn das Programm, hinter dem ich da installiert hab? Ja, guck, da kriegst du hier unten drauf. Was eigentlich sehr intuitiv ist, hätte ich jetzt zumindest gedacht. Ich fand das total toll. Dass ich also wirklich an zehn Leuten hintereinander, das hat mich total schockiert, festgestellt habe, die Leute kapieren es nicht und das sind wirklich keine dummen Leute gewesen. Und das ist halt genauso die Sache, Sachen, die im ersten Moment richtig cool erscheinen, das ist auch eine Erfahrung, die wir gemacht haben, sind es im Endeffekt gar nicht. Also wir haben das mal auf einer Konferenz, da war Ellen und ihre Truppe, die waren so freundlich und haben also einen Usability-Audit gemacht. Das heißt, die haben so einen ganz normalen, Otto-Normal-Verbraucher, vorher noch nie was mit KDE oder sonst irgendwas zu tun gehabt, vielleicht Windows, du hast halt immer irgendwie eine gewisse Vorbelastung. Und haben gesagt, okay, macht mal folgende Aufgabe. Und wir Entwickler saßen da und haben es geschüttelt, aber nicht weil wir den irgendwie ausgedacht hätten, sondern weil wir gedacht haben, Mensch, das ist doch so klar und das müssten wir eigentlich anders machen. Das ist eine echt lehrreiche Erfahrung, die ich echt jedem mal wünsche.
Was war die Aufgabe, Ellen?
Na ja, da sind wir auch bei der Methodik, wie das überhaupt funktioniert, Usability und so weiter. Wie kommen wir als sogenannte Experten eigentlich dazu, den Entwicklern zu sagen, macht das so und so, damit es besser wird. Also wir können das auch nicht aus uns selbst heraus sagen oder wir müssen wirklich den Nutzern zugucken, wie das tatsächlich funktioniert. Und dazu sitzt mal eben jemanden vor dem Rechner, gibt ihm Aufgaben, die er normalerweise im normalen Leben auch durchführen würde. Und in dem Fall war das erst mal, du hast jetzt einen neuen Rechner, den hast du irgendwie geschenkt bekommen, dass er sich auch noch ein bisschen freut. Und dann sagt man, jetzt möchtest du zuallererst das Mail-Programm einrichten. Okay, hier hast du deinen Mail-Account, richte den mal ein. Und da gab es eben schon erst mal Probleme im Konfig-Menü. Das ist unter Contact dann getrennt zwischen Identities und Server-Accounts. Das hatte der überhaupt nicht verstanden. Dann hat er endlich sein Account eingerichtet. Dann ist der Folder irgendwo erschienen. Das war ein IMAP-Folder. Der ist nicht in der normalen Inbox erschienen, sondern woanders. Und er hatte gar nicht gemerkt, dass er das tatsächlich eingerichtet hat. War völlig hilflos. Saß da, hat stundenlang danach gesucht und die Entwickler saßen wirklich unten und haben sich die Haare gerauft und haben auch nach oben gezeigt und dachten, da, da, da, da, guckt doch einfach. Aber man kann es eben nicht voraussehen, was User verstehen und was sie nicht verstehen.
Da muss ein Wizard hin.
Genau, und die allgemein billige Lösung.
Es ist für einen Entwickler halt unheimlich schwer, ein gutes User Interface zu machen, weil man natürlich total voreingenommen rangeht. Man weiß irgendwie, man kennt das Programm in und außer, nicht jede Ecke. Und dann verlangt vielleicht jemand nach einem Feature, man lässt sich gar nicht richtig beschreiben, wofür es eigentlich braucht. Und denkt so, ah cool, das bauen wir gleich mal ein. Und dann wird es halt irgendwo reingepflanscht und dann hängt es da drin. Und es gibt halt kein Feedback. Es gibt auch nicht in Firmen, die werden sowas halt machen. Usability-Tests gehören eigentlich zur Qualitätssicherung in so einem Programm dazu. Und das ist für Open Source Software tatsächlich noch was ziemlich Neues.
Es wird aber immer mehr. Also unser Projekt ja openusability.org. Da muss ich auch ein bisschen Werbung machen. Das ist eben dazu da, dass Open Source-Projekte und Usability-Leute zusammenkommen. Und da ist das Feedback ziemlich gut. Also wir haben schon 50 registrierte Projekte inzwischen. Also alles kleinere Anwendungen von KDE, Contact über Gnome, Anjuta. Das ist eine Eide, eine Entwicklungsumgebung über verschiedene Webprojekte, die sich da alle anmelden und halt auch wirklich interessiert sind, Feedback zu bekommen. Usability Feedback und das in ihren Entwicklungsprozess einzuarbeiten.
Haben wir's?
Ja, ne, also dem erst mal nichts hinzuzufügen.
Alles klar, dann danken wir für deinen Anruf. Grüßt das Sieben, Gebirge. Chaos Radio 103 und User Interfaces unser Thema. Und das beste ist natürlich Mac OS, dachte ich immer. Aber ich hab mich immer in das bessere belehren lassen.
Bis auf den Zoom-Button jetzt. Aber ich denke, alle werden anerkennen, die sich halbwegs mit User Interfaces auseinandersetzen, dass auf Mac einfach schon seit Jahren eine ganze Menge gut gelungen ist. Muss mal was zurückhaltender zu formulieren. Das ist, Apple ist halt eine Firma, die extrem viel Wert darauf legt, dass die, also die machen sich halt, bevor sie ein Produkt ausliefern, Gedanken darüber, wie es benutzt wird. Das ist einfach eine Kernüberzeugung im Laden und das merkt man halt auch. Das bedeutet nicht, dass denen alles gelingt. Und es gibt auch eine ganze Menge Sachen, die finde ich wirklich zum Kotzen und frage mich, warum muss denn das eigentlich immer noch so sein? Manches mag seine Gründe haben, manches ist auch ein bisschen sinnlos. Man merkt auch, dass sie von Release zu Release bei ihren Betriebssystemen immer viel rumspielen. Letzter Zeit eigentlich so viel, dass es schon ein bisschen anstrengend wird.
Wann kriegt denn der Mac mal eine zweite oder eine dritte Maustaste?
Der wird keine zweite Maustaste bekommen, schlicht und ergreifend, weil man sie nicht braucht. Vier von den fünf Hauptentwicklern von Macintosh seinerzeit, von dem Core-Team, die Macintosh mal geschaffen haben, waren allerdings Händler. Ich denke, das hat eine ganze Menge damit zu tun. Und klar, natürlich ist das irgendwie ganz praktisch mit dieser Kontext-Maus und so.
Es ist auf jeden Fall ein Konzept, was Leute, die von Windows kommen, ganz schwächer missen. Also ich hab Leute von Mac gesetzt, die schon lange mit Computern arbeiten, bis in die DOS-Zeit zurück. Und die waren eigentlich sehr hilflos. Ich muss sagen, es hat mich auch ein bisschen geschockt. Es war so mal ein kleiner Usability-Test. Für mich ist Mac eigentlich auch so ein User-Interface, wo ich das Gefühl hab, ist eigentlich alles sehr intuitiv. Es ist auch nicht überladen. Es gibt eigentlich immer nur so ein paar Stellen, wo man hinklicken kann, und das ist ziemlich klar. Und trotzdem sind User, die diese Oberfläche nicht gewöhnt, sind teilweise auch erst mal komplett in der Außenform.
Die was anderes gewöhnt sind.
Ja, das ist tatsächlich immer so was. Man muss sich an so ein User-Face auch gewöhnen. Und man muss es erst mal erlernen. Und die Frage ist eigentlich, wie schnell erlerne ich das? Weil, dass man irgendwas lernen muss, ist überall immer so. Es gibt eigentlich kaum Software, die man eigentlich wirklich jedem vorsetzen kann und die jeder sofort verdienen kann. Und wenn, dann ist das ein Software, die macht halt einfache Dinge. Ein Taschenrechner vielleicht. Den kann man auch nur bedienen, weil man das physikalische Gegenstück schon mal benutzt hat.
Das ist richtig, das ist richtig. Also, meine Kontextmenü, gut, die Diskussion kenn ich. Ich hab auch andere Betriebssysteme benutzt, wo das irgendwie gerade zur Religion erhoben wurde. OS2 ist da ein gutes Beispiel. Das war irgendwie Kontextmenü from hell. Kann ich sagen, dass mich das besonders produktiv gemacht hat. Gut, das ist auch nun nicht so ein Betriebssystem, was eine lange Zeit geschenkt bekommen hat um zu reifen. Ich bin natürlich auch Power-User. Ich hab dasselbe Problem wie ein Programmierer auch. Ich tue ganz viele Dinge nicht, weil ich sowieso weiß, dass die nie funktionieren würden. Von Zeit zu Zeit geht mir dann auch mal so ein kleines User Interface-Nippet natürlich verloren, weil ich das überhaupt gar nicht mehr ausprobiere. Aber natürlich will ich alles nutzen können, was geht. Ich hab hier auf meinem Mac, das ist ein bisschen albern, echt tolles, schickes, silbernes Gerät hier, aber dieses Plastik da oben, das haben sie irgendwie verkackt. Das hält nämlich meinen Schweiß nicht stand. Die linke Hand hab ich eigentlich die ganze Zeit auf dem Laptop, musst du dazu sagen. Ich schwitze hier schon dieses komische Silberplastik durch.
Es gibt Schlimmeres.
Es gibt Schlimmeres, aber man sieht das halt, wo ich halt meine Hand immer habe, nämlich links. Auf diese Kontextmenüsache kann ich sagen, warum denn nur eine Taste? Eigentlich habe ich zehn verschiedene Funktionen, die ich mit der Maus mache oder eben auch mit anderen Tasten. Ich benutze die ganze Zeit Control, Shift, Funktion, Alt und so weiter, diese ganzen Modifier. Da ist für mich Kontextmenü nur eine von mehreren. So kann man das natürlich dann auch sehen. Trotzdem, auch beim Apple ist es so, wenn man eine Maus mit zwei Tasten anschließt, dann geht das halt auch genauso, wie man das von anderen Betriebssystemen kennt. Also es ist drin, es ist nicht da. Aber es ist halt das ganze User Interface, das ist ganz wichtig, das ganze User Interface ist halt von vornherein so gebaut, dass es eben auch immer mit einem Klick geht. Dass also gar nicht erst ein Programmierer auf die Idee kommt, dass man sowas braucht.
Mit einem Klick und fünf Modifier-Tasten.
Richtig, das ist ja auch das Problem.
Ohne Modifier-Tasten, ganz ohne Modifier-Tasten. Das kann ich eigentlich durchgehend bestätigen. Das ist halt so der Grundansatz. Und das ist auch richtig so, weil du kennst das, ich meine, Usability ist das eine, im Support muss man mal gearbeitet haben. Ja, da unterhält man sich mit den Leuten übers Telefon, ja, klicken sie doch mal irgendwie jetzt da. Ja, da passiert nichts. Ja, sie müssen mit der rechten Maustaste klicken. Ah ja, und gut, dann klicken sie jetzt da. Ja, mit links oder mit rechts. Und so geht das dann irgendwie jedes Mal. Fragen die sich ja, muss ich jetzt mit dem einen oder mit dem anderen beziehungsweise eine moderne Maus, hat ja heutzutage schon drei oder vier oder fünf Tasten. Wie soll man das verstehen? Wie soll man sowas überhaupt noch vermitteln?
Klar, sind wir auch wieder bei Single und Doppelklick. Wie versteht der normale User, wann er einmal und wann er zweimal klicken soll?
Die Hälfte der Belegschaft hier in diesem Sender doppeltklickt Hyperlinks.
Ja, das ist auch immer in den Usability-Tests. Wenn man da eine ganz normale User oder auch welche, die sich wirklich viel mit dem Rechner beschäftigen, klicken immer wieder doppelt auf die Hyperlinks drauf, weil sie den Unterschied einfach nicht kennen.
Und was klickst du am liebsten? Also klickst du lieber Single oder klickst du lieber Doppel?
Ich klicke lieber Single. Ich hab das auch bei mir so eingestellt im Conquerer, im File Browser und überall auf dem Desktop und so weiter. Und verwende eben auch dann Modifier dazu.
Das ist ja relativ stark bei KDE. Also die haben mehr als alle anderen User Interfaces dieses Browser-Modell mit eingebaut, sodass man eben über alles wie über eine Webseite geht. Das ganze World Wide Web ist ja im Prinzip eine Antithese zu den normalen User Interfaces, dadurch, dass man halt eigentlich nie einen Doppelklick macht, auch wenn vielleicht alle spätestens dann den Doppelklick machen, wenn sie der Meinung waren, einmal klicken reicht. Hat nicht genug Ergebnis gebracht. Ja, vielleicht muss ich zweimal klicken. Ich benutze wiederum in Textverarbeitungsprogrammen sehr gerne auch Triple- und Quadruple-Click. Das hat auch sinnvolle Funktionen, wenn man das beherrscht. Also, weißt du, was ich meine?
Ja, ja, ja, ich frage mich nur gerade, wozu das führt. Wozu?
Na, ein Doppelklick markiert ein Wort, ein Triple-Click markiert eine Zeile und ein Quadruple-Click markiert einen Absatz. Und dann kann man halt, wenn man den letzten Klick hält, mitracken.
Ich weiß ja, ein Quintuple-Click auf die Shift-Taste bei Windows.
Das hängt mehr vom Programm ab als vom Betriebssystem. Das funktioniert auch nicht durchgehend bei Mac, so wie ich es gerne hätte. Aber früher mit FrameMaker war das ganz großartig. Aber, ah, du musst jetzt das Software töten. Wie auch immer. Auf jeden Fall, wenn man halt gut damit ist, ich habe immer die Erfahrung, wenn ich jemand an meinen Laptop setze, dann kann er mit meinem Computer gar nichts anfangen, weil ich mir das so katastrophal für ihn eingestellt habe, dass man überhaupt nicht klarkommt. Du hattest, glaube ich, diesen Effekt mal. Erst mal fliegen alle Fenster an, links und rechts. Und dann bleibt halt die Maus hängen, weil ich halt auch irgendwie klicke mit dem Trackpad und dann auch klicken und draggen und halten und so weiter. Das mache ich halt alles damit. Da muss man natürlich extrem gut damit umgehen können, um das überhaupt benutzen zu können.
Ich habe noch einen Anrufer zur rechten Maustasse.
Ich wollte eigentlich nur ganz kurz zwischen dich noch den Kommentar bringen, dass es, habt ihr auch schon angesprochen, dass es auf dem Mac ja sehr wohl die zweite Maustaste gibt und dass das eigentlich auch super funktioniert. Also ich habe damals vom Windows auf Mac gewechselt, eigentlich auch nur deshalb, weil die rechte Maustaste unterstützt wird und weil überall auch das Chaosrad funktioniert. Ich bin mehr als glücklich mittlerweile, ja.
Das heißt, bist du ein Switcher? Also bist du von Windows komplett auf Mac oder hast du außerdem noch einen Mac?
Es geht leider nicht ganz ohne PC. Aber das meiste mache ich mittlerweile tatsächlich mit meinem Powerbook.
Und wie ist das? Also ich meine, wie war der Wechsel für dich so?
Ziemlich, ziemlich schmerzlos. Ich hatte gedacht, ich habe mehr Probleme. Also ich kam damals mit dem OS 9 überhaupt nicht klar. Und seit OS X ging das eigentlich alles recht gut. Ich kann meine Dokumente weiter verwenden. Meine Programme habe ich halbwegs umgestellt auf Mac.
Ist es nur so, dass du keine Schmerzen hast oder ist auch irgendwas besser?
Ja besser ist es auf jeden Fall. Schon allein deshalb, weil die ganze Oberfläche einfach ein bisschen integrierter ist als auf Windows. Meiner Meinung nach. Es kommt schöner. Ich mag halt natürlich auch diesen ganzen Effekt, wenn meine Fenster durch die Gegend fliegen.
Ich sag doch, ist das hübsch.
Allein das Anfassen und dieses damit umgehen. Das macht einfach Spaß.
Ich will dich mal was fragen, was sehr umstritten ist. Und alle halten mich für wahnsinnig. Aber hast du dieses Gefühl, dass die Maus sich anders bewegt auf dem Mac?
Ja, fand ich ganz grausam. Lässt sich eben auch umstellen. Also ist bestimmt auch Gewöhnungssache. Ich fand's grausam. Ich kam damit nicht klar. Es gibt aber ein Windows, es gibt einen Microsoft Driver für die Maus. Und dann läuft die auch sowieso auf...
Inwiefern anders bewegt?
Die Beschleunigung ist anders.
Also die Art und Weise, wie tatsächlich der Mauszeiger von der Maus bewegt wird. Ich kann's dir auch nicht technisch erklären. Es muss da was anders sein. Aber wenn ich vom Windows rechne, ich werd wahnsinnig. Also vielleicht nicht besser oder schlechter, aber auf jeden Fall anders. Okay, aber du hast auch was bemerkt.
Ich kam mit der Mac Beschleunigung nicht klar.
Das ist wieder so eine Geschmacksfrage. Bei vielen Sachen ist es entweder so Matter of Taste oder Gewöhnung. Das will man dann auch nicht aufgeben. Man muss einen schon jemanden zwingen, mal eine Woche lang mit der anderen Mausbeschleunigung zu arbeiten. Vielleicht will man dann wieder zurück.
Oder man muss eben viel Zeit haben. Wenn man die Arbeitsumgebung wechselt und wirklich im Stress ist und Dinge tun muss, die jetzt einfach funktionieren sollen, dann ist die Stressgrenze sehr viel geringer. Man wird sich ganz sehr viel früher ärgern, als wenn man einfach mal eine Woche Urlaub hat und sagt, jetzt probiere ich mal meinen Mac aus und mache dann nur Dinge zum Spaß.
Hast du sonst noch irgendwelche Feststellungen gemacht bei der Umstellung vom User Interface?
Was mich mal interessiert ist, wie ist das denn mit den OK-Tasten? Weil das ist ja so ein Punkt, wo sich nicht nur der Mac und Windows unterscheiden, sondern auch Gnome und KDE sich unterscheiden. Wo ist der OK-Button im Dialog? Also unten hat man ja üblicherweise OK und Abbrechen und vielleicht auch noch zwei, drei andere Funktionen. Und beim Macintosh ist es halt rechts immer OK oder der Button, der den Dialog quasi bestätigt. Und das Abbrechen ist ganz links. Und bei Windows ist es genau andersrum.
Ach echt?
Tatsächlich nicht, weil mich macht das schon nervös so. Ich hab so ein paar Programme, die das noch andersrum machen. Und wenn ich die habe, dann will ich die eigentlich ganz schnell loswerden. Weil ich das unheimlich störend empfinde, wenn irgendwie der OK-Button muss halt schon irgendwie immer in der gleichen Ecke sein.
Ja, aber ist er ja immer rechts.
Auf Mac ist er immer rechts. Und Gnome ist er auch immer rechts. Und es gibt halt Leute, die drehen fast durch, weil das ihrem Prinzip widerspricht. Sie argumentieren halt, ich lese von links nach rechts, also muss der OK-Button nach links.
Ich würde aus demselben Grund sagen, dass er nach rechts muss.
Ja, eben, weil rechts ist halt auch die Return-Taste. Man muss immer gucken, was dominiert jetzt eigentlich? Ist es unser Lesesystem mit links und rechts oder dominiert der Rechtshänder? Was würdest denn du meinen?
Das liegt an der Persönlichkeit und natürlich auch an der Gewöhnung. Es gibt dazu jede Menge Studien, aber eindeutige Ergebnisse gibt es nicht. Ob jetzt der, okay, Button links oder rechts sein sollte. Und das ist eine Religion.
Gibt es Rückschlüsse auf die Persönlichkeit? Kann man Aussagen machen über die Persönlichkeit des Users?
Nee, ich würde sagen eine Einstellungssache eher.
Links-Button-Clicker sind schlechtere Menschen.
Links-Button-Clicker sind...
Nein, das sind natürlich die besseren.
Die fressen auch kleine Kinder.
Was ich mir aber wünschen würde, wäre, dass ich nicht nur mit Return das OK drücke und mit Escape das abbrechen, sondern vielleicht auch die zweite und die dritte Option, die ich da noch drin habe. Wenn ich eine Mail wegklicke, dann fragte mich, ob ich die sichern will. Ich könnte theoretisch nicht sichern, anklicken. Und da konnte ich früher, in OS 7 zumindest, habe ich ein N gedrückt für den Anfangsbuchstaben der Option, die ich hatte. Und er hat gesagt, er hat genau diese Option auch. Das funktioniert bei mir nicht.
Eine schöne Sache ist aber auch das.
In OS 7 ging es aber einfach nur so, einfach ohne irgendwie einen Affengriff.
Haben sie jetzt aber auf Apfel-Tralala umgestellt. Aber unser Anrufer wollte gerade was sagen.
Natürlich. Eine Sache, die auch noch unterschiedlich ist, ist das Starten von Programmen oder von Auswahlen, die auf Windows mit der Enter-Taste gehen. Das ist noch so ein bisschen die Umstellung. Und Mac war, ich hab's jetzt gerade...
Apfel-O. Apfel unten.
Apfel-O.
Apfel-O und unten.
Okay, oder Apfel unten.
Sowohl als auch.
Ja, teilweise ist es, denk ich mal, ein bisschen sicherer. Einfach, falls ich irgendwo mal auf Enter komme und ein Programm ausführe, was eigentlich in der Theorie nie passiert. Aber, naja, gewinnt man sich auch relativ schnell dran.
Na ja, und ich weiß gar nicht, ob das noch so ist, aber als Windows-User, wenn man versucht, ein Ad zu schreiben, Steuerung, Alt und Q hat früher immer unter Mac die Anwendung geschlossen. Und wenn man dann gerade zur Web-Formule eingeben war, ok, es bin nur das User, schön, Blut, Steuerung, Alt, Q, boah, alles weg. Das war sehr ärgerlich.
Philipp, vielen Dank für deinen Anruf.
Dann Fritz in Pankow, dann 102, 6. Fritz Info.
Heute Nacht wird's richtig wolkig. Stellenweise kann's sogar ein bisschen Regen geben bei Temperaturen zwischen 10 und 15 Grad. Morgen noch wolkiger als heute. Bis zum Abend soll es aber immerhin trocken bleiben. Die Höchsttemperaturen liegen zwischen 21 und 26 Grad. Und die Meldungen hat Gerald Kötter-Einrich.
Die beiden in Afghanistan getöteten Bundeswehrsoldaten sind nach Deutschland überführt worden. Eine Luftwaffenmaschine mit den Särgen an Bord landete am Abend auf dem militärischen Teil des Kölner Flughafens. Die Soldaten waren vor vier Tagen im Nordosten Afghanistans getötet worden, als beim Verladen von Munition drei Lastwagen explodierten. Das Verfahren um die Vertrauensfrage im Bundestag stößt auch bei SPD-Politikern auf starke Bedenken. Die Bundestagsabgeordnete Hoffmann will deshalb das Bundesverfassungsgericht in Karlsruhe anrufen. Sie habe Zweifel, ob die unechte Vertrauensfrage von Bundeskanzler Schröder mit dem Grundgesetz übereinstimme. Schröder selbst will sich am Freitag bei der Vertrauensfrage der Stimme enthalten. Das Arbeitslosengeld II in Ostdeutschland soll auf Westniveau angehoben werden. Der Hartz IV-Ombudsrat schlug in seinem Zwischenbericht vor, künftig einheitlich 345 Euro zu zahlen. Wirtschaftsminister Clement will die Empfehlung umsetzen. Die Weltgesundheitsorganisation WHO sieht wichtige Ziele ihres Kampfes gegen die Immunschwäche Krankheit AIDS gefährdet. Bis zum Jahresende sollten 3 Millionen Menschen in armen Ländern Zugang zu AIDS-Medikamenten erhalten. Dies sei nicht mehr zu schaffen, weil es an Geldfehle, teilte die WHO in Genf mit. Nach ihren Berechnungen sind mindestens weitere 18 Milliarden US-Dollar nötig, um den Kampf gegen AIDS in den nächsten drei Jahren erfolgreich zu führen. Fußball-Weltmeister Brasilien hat den Confederations Cup gewonnen. Die Brasilianer besiegten im Endspiel Argentinien mit 4 zu 1. Zuvor hatte die deutsche Mannschaft in Leipzig den dritten Platz erreicht, die Nationalelf gewann gegen Mexiko 4 zu 3 nach Verlängerung. Das entscheidende Tor schoss Michael Balak. Der Verkehr Fritz keine aktuellen Meldungen. Gute Fahrt.
Danke Gerald. 5 nach halb 1.
Kommenden Montag freuen sich die Radio Fritzen am Nachmittag über ein kleines, feines und natürlich exklusives Radiokonzert live in den Fritz Studios. Mit 2-Raumwohnung. 2-Raumwohnung und Valentine. Das exklusive Fritz Radiokonzert live in den Fritz Studios. Kommen im Montag ab 16 Uhr und im Radio.
Wesbro dich, est des Lied dich singen. Ich arbeite ja bisweilen auch noch in Frankfurt. Beim Schwester-Sender. Und da gibt es tatsächlich sowas. Also da gibt es tatsächlich einen Moment, an dem du deine Stimme kippen lassen musst. Das gehört also praktisch zu dir. Nein, das nicht. Ein Teufel werde ich tun.
Aber es ist so ähnlich wie WNBC.
Genau, es ist so ähnlich wie WNBC. Und ich weigere mich auch kategorisch das zu tun. Alle finden mich deswegen total lässig. Dabei kann ich das einfach nur, mich ohne einen Husten-Anfall zu kriegen oder so. Das ist echt krass. Da musst du so reden. Ich habe auch gedacht, die wollen mich verarschen. Weil bei diesem Film war das ja auch WNBC. Entschuldigung, das ist doch ein Witz, oder? Interessanterweise hat sich das derselbe Typ ausgedacht, der bei einem anderen Schwester-Sender in Sachsen. Das ist so was Ähnliches, also dann machen die eine Pause, wenn die den Verkehr, glaube ich, ansagen. Dann lassen die einfach eine dreisequentige Pause, damit die Leute denken, oh, es ist was kaputt. Ich habe keine Ahnung, was der Tineff soll.
Wir wollen hier aber nicht, sondern wir wollen Chaos Radio 103 auf Fritz.
Hier ist WCCC und Sie hören Chaos Radio auf Fritz.
Chaos Radio 103, User Interfaces, unser Endspurt.
Wir waren gerade bei tollen Katastrophen. Der religiöse Krieg will hier so recht nicht ausbrechen.
Ich habe noch einen kleinen Nachschlag vor den Nachrichten. Ich habe noch Rolf angerufen. Der weiß, wie man sich von einem System ans andere gewöhnt.
Ja, ich wollte erst mal sagen, dass ich vor kurzem Linux installiert habe. Auf einem alten Rechner. Da muss ich sagen, dass ich überhaupt nicht mit dem Doppelklick klarkomme. Wenn ich jetzt irgendwie eine Datei geklickt habe, dann ist die sofort aufgehangen. Ich hatte vorher Windows. Und das mich tierisch angekotzt hat, dass die Datei sofort aufgehangen ist.
Das kann man doch ausschalten.
Ja, ich weiß, aber ich kann nur sagen, dass ich damit überhaupt nicht klarkomme.
Die Frage sind natürlich schon die Defaults. Ich finde es eigentlich auch, wenn ich die Datei anklick, dann will ich die auswählen, um damit was anderes zu machen, sie vielleicht irgendwo wieder einzufügen.
Ja, oder um die jetzt irgendwie zu kopieren oder so. Und dann ist die sofort, zack, offen.
Wie mache ich das denn dann, wenn ich also...
Du kannst dann ein Modifier dazu nehmen. Also wenn du dazu Steuerung klickst oder sowas, dann ist sie eben nur ausgewählt. Du nimmst eben gleich die Tasten, um nach oben und unten zu kommen. Das ist eine Geschmacksfrage.
In der anderen Richtung ist es halt auch wieder schwierig. So Leute, die von einem Single-Click-User-Interface kommen, beziehungsweise von einem Double-Click-User-Interface kommen, die starten halt Anwendungen ständig zweimal. Du klickst halt in dein Panel irgendwie und machst natürlich einen Doppelklick und dann hast du zweimal den Browser offen.
Ja, das wird ja von den meisten Umgebungen jetzt auch schon abgefangen, dass eben, wenn innerhalb von einem bestimmten Intervall geklickt wird, dass dann trotzdem nur einmal gestartet wird.
Das ist nicht schlecht. Und dann würde ich mir sagen, aber ich weiß nicht, ob jetzt auch nicht, dass der Rechner so alt ist. Und zwar, wenn ich jetzt irgendwie auf den Conqueror klicke, dann habe ich immer die Uhr und dann, wie es nicht fünf Sekunden lang, kommt nichts und dann kommt erst der Conqueror. Und das nervt mich irgendwie tierisch, weil unten rechts diese Taskleiste sieht man immer schon, den. Man kann ihn noch anklicken, aber es passiert nichts.
Ist dein Computer nicht schnell genug?
Ich habe echt keinen Plan, weil das kotzt mir jetzt hier an.
Du kannst einfach eine Linux-Telefon für fünf Jahre annehmen. Da funktioniert das alles rasend schnell auf deinem fünf Jahre alten Rechner.
Das ist aber glaube ich nicht mehr clicky-bunt in dem Maße.
Dann ist es leider noch nicht so benutzbar, weil da hat sich dann doch einiges getan in letzter Zeit.
Rolf, trotzdem, sei mutig, halt durch.
Werde ich machen.
Und schöne Nacht noch.
Ja, danke schön.
Ja, ich bin hier gerade nochmal so die Punkte durchgegangen, die wir noch nicht so richtig erwähnt haben und die von den Leuten um den Vorfeld auf unserer tollen Mitmachseite in der Wikipedia, sehr erfolgreiches Modell. Vielen Dank für die Beteiligung, erwähnt haben. Da ist so einiges drin, was wir schon erwähnt haben. Ein paar Sachen werden wir leider weglassen müssen, weil irgendwo sind drei Stunden auch echt zu viel. Aber ein paar Dinge müssen unbedingt mal angesprochen werden. Zum Beispiel gibt es noch diesen schönen Begriff des Spatial Browsing oder generell Spatial User Interfaces. Also Spatial räumlich bedeutet das. Und da gibt es natürlich schon so einige Aspekte, da wirst du sicherlich auch noch das eine oder andere zu erzählen können. Um mal ein Beispiel zu geben, in Windows, und auch in der KDE und auch in der Gnome, da kannst du mich vielleicht gleich nochmal korrigieren, aber unter Windows auf jeden Fall gibt es halt dieses Konzept, dass das Menü eines Programms in dem Fenster des Programms ist. Das bedeutet, ist das Fenster woanders, ist auch das Menü woanders. Während bei Macintosh es eine Menüzeile gibt, die oben immer das Menü des aktiven Programms, also das im Vordergrund befindliche Programms anzeigt, mit dem netten Effekt, dass ich eben dasselbe auch immer an derselben Stelle habe, egal welches Programm ich arbeite. Sprich, in dem Moment, wo ein System es schafft, Gleiches an der gleichen Stelle zu bringen, muss ich mir weniger Orte einprägen und vor allem ich muss halt weniger suchen. Was hast du da so für Erfahrungen zu gesammelt?
Ja, da gibt es ja sogar ein Gesetz, ein Usability-Gesetz, das heißt Fitts Law, dass eben, naja, große Flächen und auch an den Ecken des Bildschirms, diese Punkte sind eben ganz besonders zugänglich, weil man mit der Maus einfach hinfeuern kann. Man muss die nicht irgendwie abbremsen, wenn die Menüleiste in einem Fenster drin ist, da muss man eben an einem bestimmten Punkt aufhören mit der Mausbewegung, um das zu treffen. Und wenn es eben ganz oben am Rand ist, kann man einfach nach oben feuern und trifft eben schnell das Menü. Da gab es auch jede Menge Untersuchungen zu, die eben bestätigt haben, dass die Menüleiste oben am Bildschirmrand auch wirklich tatsächlich schneller ist. Allerdings stammen die alle noch aus Zeiten, als man mehr oder minder im Vollbildmodus gearbeitet hat. Und jetzt heute, wo man eben viele verschiedene Fenster auf hat, ist es eben manchmal doch praktisch, wenn man die Menüleiste im Fenster drin hat. Und vor allem haben ja viele gerade Linux-Systeme dieses tolle Feature, Focus Follows Mouse. Also das heißt, wenn ich meine Maus über den Bildschirm bewege, dann wird eben immer das Fenster, das unten drunter liegt unter der Maus, bekommt automatisch den Fokus. Und wenn ich jetzt halt von einem Fenster ganz unten rechts über andere Fenster hochziehe, um zur Menüleiste zu kommen, weiß ich im Endeffekt gar nicht, von welchem Fenster jetzt die Menüleiste oben ist. Focus Follows Mouse heißt das?
Das hat mich sowas von rund gemacht, bis ich begriffen habe, was ich falsch mache. Was soll das denn?
Wenn man zum Beispiel was in der Zwischenablage hat, man verliert seine Auswahl nicht, wenn man ins nächste Fenster geht, sondern geht einfach mit der Maus drüber, hat den Fokus und man ist da, wo man immer war.
Wenn man es begriffen hat, ist das praktisch.
Man muss sich extra klicken oder die Taste verwenden.
Apple scheut das, wie der Teufel das weiß.
Ja, weil es ja nicht funktioniert in Apple.
Aber es funktioniert natürlich tatsächlich nicht, aus dem Grund, den du da gerade gesagt hast. Was interessant ist, Befits Law sagt ja nicht nur was über die Ecken des Screens, sondern das sagt eigentlich vor allen Dingen auch, dass man schnell an den Punkt kommen soll, dass User Interface Elemente möglichst nah am Maus-Cursor positioniert sein sollen. Und da widerspricht sich es dann natürlich wieder so ein bisschen. Da ist ja eigentlich die Menüzeile gleich oben in meinem Fenster viel näher als die, die oben am Screenrand klebt.
Na ja, es hat eher was mit der Maus-Bewegung zu tun. Also das heißt, wenn ganz nah ein großes Element ist, komme ich dann natürlich auch schnell hin, weil ich dann einfach nur eine kleine Bewegung habe. Aber wenn ich ein Target habe, das weit entfernt ist, wo ich aber ungebremst hinziehen kann, hinpfeffern kann, dann funktioniert das eben auch.
Ich wollte halt nur anmerken, dass es wahrscheinlich nicht immer möglich ist, einfach so drei, vier Usability-Gesetze aufzuschreiben und seine Anwendung danach dann versuchen zu beurteilen.
Ja, das ist das große Problem der Usability. Man muss eben doch, wie ich schon gesagt habe, immer die Benutzer im Kontext sehen und es dann dementsprechend anpassen.
Unser letzter Anruf war, war sehr begeistert von der Einheitlichkeit von Macintosh Betriebssystem. Da liegt ja zugrunde, dass es da schon immer eigentlich bei Apple ganz klare Guidelines gab. Anwendungen, die sich nicht an diese Guidelines halten, gibt es eigentlich nicht auf diesem Betriebssystem. Die werden dann nicht zugelassen sozusagen.
Na die sterben einen schnellen Tod. Das ist immer sehr auffällig. Es gibt diesen schönen Begriff Mac-like. Man definiert eine Anwendung danach, ob sie Mac-like ist oder nicht. Wenn etwas Mac-like ist, dann hat es gute Überlebenschancen. Wenn es nicht Mac-like ist, dann ist es geradezu verbannt. Software verschwindet schneller, als sie gekommen ist vom Markt, weil niemand sie mag.
Komm, sieben Minuten haben wir noch manchmal die sieben Kostbarkeit der Usability.
Es gibt natürlich zu diesem ganzen Thema auch interessante Webseiten. userinterfacehallofshame.com zum Beispiel ist irgendwie ein Webblog, was ich diesen ganzen Fragen furchtbarer User Interfaces widmete. Das liest dich ganz lustig, was auch immer wieder ein Klassiker ist, sind solche Dialogfenster. Ich hasse sie. Also das ist wirklich eine der schlimmsten Dinge überhaupt. Und auch so ein typischer Programmierer, denk nicht nach, Bug. So ein Dialogfenster, der halt hochkommt und dir so zwei Möglichkeiten bietet, weiterzumachen. Und die eine Möglichkeit heißt Ja und die andere heißt Nein. Welchen klickst du?
Na, üblicherweise steht da auch noch eine Frage oben drüben.
Genau, aber die muss man halt dann auch erst mal lesen. Und was noch viel schlimmer ist, man muss sie verstehen. Und wenn das halt so eine Frage ist, du hast doch so ein super geiles Beispiel von denen gehabt, mit dieser Zeitzone, hast du das irgendwie noch mal? Also mein Klassiker ist immer so, diese Datei nicht löschen, ja nein, entscheiden sie in den nächsten zehn Sekunden. So, da kommt man so gleich ins flimmern. Und ja nein fragen, falsch so verstehen, ist sehr einfach, weil man muss halt nur irgendeine Negation oder vielleicht im schlimmsten Fall sogar doppelte Negation oder nicht richtig verstehen, das ist ja dann auch in unterschiedlichen Sprachen anders. Wenn ein Deutscher eine englische doppelte Negation liest, die eigentlich verstärkend wirkt, interpretiert er sie unter Umständen genau andersrum und es ist alles eine große Katastrophe. Eigentlich bei Mac ist es so recht stringent mittlerweile durchgehalten. Es gibt natürlich da auch ein paar Ausnahmen, aber Gott sei Dank nur sehr wenige. Da wird halt in den jungen Interface Guidelines vorgeschrieben, dass ein Button die Aktion auszudrücken hat, die dann geschieht, wenn man ihn klickt. Also löschen oder eben nicht löschen oder solche Sachen, damit man eben nicht immer den ganzen Text lesen und verstehen kann.
Das sollte eigentlich reichen, nur die Buttons zu lesen.
Kannst du mal die Frage dann nochmal...
Ja, also man muss dazu sagen, es wurde nicht so implementiert. Der Entwickler wusste vorher schon, dass es nicht so ganz verständlich ist und hat es dann auch nochmal an uns geschickt, an die Usability Leute. The time zone setting was changed. Do you want to keep the absolute time of the items in your calendar, which will show them to be at a different time than before or move them to be at the old time also in the new time zone?
Was?
Ja, Gott sei Dank wurde es nicht wahr.
Ich meine, die Frage ist nicht ganz unberechtigt, aber die kann man doch so nicht stellen.
Genau, das hat der Entwickler auch selbst erkannt und vorher zur Review eben geschickt.
Die Frage kann man doch so gar nicht stellen. Das ist etwas, was viele Leute, also viele Programmierer nicht schaffen, aus welchen Gründen auch immer, überhaupt die Interaktion mit dem User zu dem Zeitpunkt, wo sie stattfinden muss, schon so weit reduziert zu haben, dass er einfach auch eine Verständnisschance besitzt. Ganz schwieriges Ding. Also es gibt ja auch immer so Dreher. Wenn man sein Windows runterfährt, wo muss man hingehen?
Start.
Ins Startmenü, genau. Oder beim Mac, was sie auch erst mit Mac OS X geändert haben, um die Diskette auszuwerfen, wirft man sie in den Papierkorb. Also für den erfahrenen User halt so, naja, so macht man das halt. Aber jeder Neujusern so, oh nein, ich darf ja jetzt noch nicht meine Daten löschen noch, bevor ich jetzt die Diskette wieder aufstelle.
Diskette gelöscht. Ich hatte mal eine Fehlermeldung, die hieß diese Meldung. Und die konnte ich bestätigen mit Ja. Das war Windows übrigens auch.
Oder der Klassiker auch. No keyboard present. Ja super.
Die Musik ist zu Ende.
Eine beliebige Taste drücken, um fortzufahren oder eine andere um abzubrechen.
Ich muss eine beliebige Taste drücken. Wollen wir noch gucken? Vielleicht haben wir noch 3 Minuten. 0331 77 97 110 Wir begeben uns auf den Standtisch und fragen mal, was ihr für kranke Fehlermeldungen gerade so auf der Tasche habt. Währenddessen kannst du weiter reden, Tim.
Ja, nicht. Eines der Katastrophen auf deiner Liste hab ich gerade noch gesehen. Das sind Tabulatoren in Windows. Das ist auch was, was mich wirklich wahnsinnig macht.
Oh, die Tabs. Ja, die sind ganz grausam.
Es gibt halt diese Dialoge, die einfach so an die 20 Tabulatoren haben und die passen dann nicht mehr in eine Reihe. Und dann fangen sie an, sie in mehreren Reihen übereinander zu stapeln. Und das hat diesen Effekt, dass natürlich der, der ausgewählt ist, das muss natürlich unten sein, damit er diesen Reiter machen kann. Und das bedeutet, dass sich ständig diese Zeilen vertauschen und jede Aktion in dem Dialog verändert den Dialog komplett und sortiert alles um.
Und das geht natürlich wirklich gar nicht, dass ein User Interface Element in dem Moment durch die Gegend hüpft, wo man es versucht zu benutzen. Das ist ja ein ganz, ganz, ganz grausames Ding.
Guten Abend, Jakob.
Ich hab noch eine Fehlermeldung für euch. Und zwar hab ich eine Grafikkarte installiert und da kam die tolle Meldung, ein oder mehrere Grafikkarten wurden erfolgreich installiert und ein oder mehrere konnten nicht erfolgreich installiert werden. Das ist dann sehr weit.
Wie viele Grafikkarten hast du eingebaut?
Ja, eine oder mehrere.
Oh ja, viele Meldungen natürlich, dass wir das vergessen haben. Ich hab auch eine Lieblingsfehlermeldung. Die hatte ich auch tatsächlich mal auf dem Mac und die hieß Not enough memory to display the...
Naja, oder die klassische Windows-Weldung Kein Weltraum links vom Gerät.
Bitte was? Bitte was?
Kein Weltraum links vom Gerät. No space left on device.
Das stand da nicht wirklich, oder?
Es muss tatsächlich in der frühen Windows-Welt so eine Übersetzung gegeben haben.
Ja, ich will Famous Last Words auch für diese Sendung, würde ich sagen. Das war das Chaosradio 103. Genau.
Hoffentlich demnächst auch als Podcast. Viele haben schon nachgefragt. Jetzt wo es dieses Feature auch in iTunes gibt, wollen das natürlich alle haben. Hätten wir eigentlich schon lange haben müssen. Mal gucken, ist ja eigentlich kein großes Problem.
Wir kümmern uns drum.
Irgendwann mal müsste man mal, .de. Ja, super, danke, dass ihr zugehört habt. Und hier auch die Beteiligung im Chat war mal wieder sehr unterhaltsam. Insofern, nächsten Monat geht's weiter.
Ja, Chaosradio 104 am letzten Mittwoch im Monat.
Genau, das ist dann so der erste Tag. Also die allermeisten von uns werden dann schon in Holland sein, bei der vorhin schon erwähnten Veranstaltung. What the heck? Mal gucken, ob wir da in irgendeiner Form Bezug nehmen können. Ich denke, die eine oder andere Live-Berichterstattung könnte stattfinden, weil da ist ja dann schon eine Menge los. Und Thema gibt's aber noch nicht.
Warum kommt denn Fritz mit dem Ü-Wagen nicht rüber?
Das ist schon ein bisschen weiter weg, aber ich glaube auch, das wäre schon alles viel zu verstrahlt.
Das wird jetzt auch noch ziemlich lange dauern, um zu erklären, warum das nicht so einfach möglich ist. Chaosradio 104 am letzten Mittwoch im Juli 2005. Das war Chaosradio 103. Ab 1 Uhr gibt's den Night Flight mit Martin Petersdorf. Danke Ellen, danke Sven, danke Tim. Mein Name ist Holger Klein. Danke für die Aufmerksamkeit, tschüss.